there we go good morning everybody a
little after 10 so we'll get going here
i'll be filling in for chairman
infantine while he is
introducing a bill elsewhere i'd like to
start off
with the
pledge of allegiance and ask
representative warden if he would lead
us in the pledge of allegiance please
next we'll go ahead and have the clerk
call the roll
infantine absent seaworth
avelino
callum
myself mackie here
nunes
warden
turcotte yep
proud
sullivan
susie
berudi
cahill
lisa vestro
schmidt
toomey
bouchard
yep toomey here uh bouchard
here
minimal here
okay
okay it is a little after 10 we'll open
up the hearing on hb
and i believe to present representative
adjutant
all right thank you mr chairman and
members of the labor committee
i'm here today to introduce
hp 1053 a bill which would provide time
and a half for any employee who was
asked or more often called in to work
hours with which they were not
previously scheduled
the bill is on
the other side of the coin of hb 1094
bill will hear later
that would require employees receive at
least seven day notice of their rest
periods
it wasn't coordinated but this feels
kind of like an ever or
if the house finds it unnecessary or
dangerous for
two employers for them to have to notify
an employee a week ahead of time what
their schedule is expected to be then
they at least then the least they could
do is pay them a little more for the
sacrifice that employee is making for
the benefit of the company whether it's
through surprise scheduling or being
called into work the idea behind the
bill is simple employees have lives
they may use their time off to do chores
or errands or spend time with their
loved ones or god forbid rest
the bill does two things to help secure
that time off it first ensures that an
employer really needs that employee to
come in by making it so they have to be
paid a little more
and be paid the time and half for their
work
the other thing it does is that if the
employer decides yeah we do really need
you to come in that employee is better
compensated for having to rearrange
their schedule because there are often
costs associated with that i want to
refer really quickly to a recent article
in nh business review and i want to
preface um that i really appreciate the
folks they quoted on the other side of
the debate on this bill i love the
timberland owners i love their employees
i submitted biomass legislation the 2020
session so this isn't in any way
adversarial to them but it's definitely
a disagreement
um the mem person that they quoted said
quote you take a shot of rain and say
take the afternoon off let's work all
day on saturday and then they'll say pay
me overtime it wasn't scheduled which is
frankly the point of the bill
i want to deconstruct that bit about the
surprise saturday scheduling
logging in timber employee expects to
have that saturday off maybe his kid has
a community center soccer game maybe
that's the only day he can get during
the day or during the week to visit a
family member in a nursing home who's an
hour away if he lives in any of the
northern counties
maybe they planned on spending that day
coaching or resting or anything
presumably that person had made plans
for that day
9 a.m boss sends a text that says it's
raining see you on saturday at 9. well
now that person is in the position of
not only having to rearrange all of that
if they're so lucky to be able to but if
they have a younger kid and their
parents were like mine growing up where
they worked opposite schedules to try to
get out of child care
well now they have 48 hours to try to
find child care that either doesn't
exist or it's more expensive because
it's the weekend and and last minute and
you know what frankly after that yes i
do think that person deserves time and a
half for that trouble it's not just
weather dependent jobs many low wage 29
hour a week employee or employers also
keep their employees in this awful
guessing game about when they're working
and when they're needed and even some
40-hour a week employers do this as well
i want to extend some power to those
employees to help balance that
relationship out a little bit and as
such i would ask the committee otp this
bill thank you
thank you representative any uh
questions for representative adjutant
representative
thank you
how would this bill interact if the
employee was already due time and a half
due to having worked that many hours
that week
um
that is a good question that i honestly
don't know the answer to
okay a follow-up
could you foresee that maybe an employee
if they had an employer if they had two
employees one that was
already over the number of hours where
they had to be paid time and a half and
one that wasn't
they might focus all the unscheduled
work on the employee that was already
due time and a half because
at least according to one reading this
bill it would be no different
because that employee would already be
in the time and a half category
um well if
if i understand the question and uh the
second employee has less hours on the
schedule
um then
i believe you know that would be
shifting the hours around in a way that
protects as much time off for both
employees as possible
thank you
any other questions representative
avalon
thank you mr chairman thank you for the
representative for testifying today
taking our questions
how does this affect salaried employees
my understanding is that
salary employees are in a position
already
where
their hours are
pretty well dictated by their employer
so i don't think that they would be
amenable to this
or i don't think this would impact that
if their schedule is already pretty flux
go ahead
thank you um so if a salaried employee
was to cover a shift for a
hourly employee or vice versa would the
hourly employee be mandated the employer
be mandated to pay the hourly employee
time and a half but not the salary
employee for covering the same shift
if
i believe that would be the case
um
if
if the hours are unscheduled and they're
not in a salary agreement where
they
their hours are
less structured in a typical nine to
five or eight to four setting
then um yes
and one last follow-up mr chairman one
blast follow-up thank you and how would
this apply to part-time employees is it
still
where employers only open four or five
hours a day and an employee comes in for
covers that four or five hour shift
still mandated to pay time and half to
that part-time employee yes
thank you mr chairman
are there any other questions
representative cahill
could you turn on your mike
thank you thank you mr sharon thank you
representative for taking my question
uh would you believe that sometimes
employers will penalize the employee for
declining
the opportunity to come in the
unscheduled hours
i i thank you for the question that i
would um i would absolutely believe that
um
the the main thrust of the bill is to
provide
a little more
power balance between the employer and
employee as far as
time that that employee originally
perceived they had off uh it raises a
stake for the employer a little bit
to say okay well i really need you to
come in
and i understand that you're sacrificing
personal life things uh such as any of
the family commitments that i had
mentioned and as a consequence of that
uh you're going to receive uh more in
pay so that is the intention there
thank you
are there any other questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you representative
edgerton thank you
i have many many cards on this bill um
i'd like to start with rudy ogden please
sorry good morning thank you for the
record rudy ogden deputy commissioner
department of labor um my being mindful
everyone's time i don't want to be
overly redundant i would say that for
purposes of administration of this bill
we did have same or some of the similar
questions to what we've heard
namely how would payment be handled in
certain scenarios our reading of this
bill would suggest that salaried
individuals would not be entitled
to an enhancement additionally per diem
employees would not be entitled to an
enhancement but that's just something we
wanted clarification on
because as presently prescribed we would
see it as not
allowing for them to get an enhancement
the other question we had relative to
administration
i know there's a bill later on uh hb
1094 dealing with scheduling
but i think that one thing to note is
not all employers have what would be
considered a static or clearly
established scheduling procedure so
where this talks about
employees subject to a change in
scheduling outside of the normal
scheduling procedure we would just want
to know
you know if we're dealing with an
employer that has a little bit of a more
ad hoc scheduling which is problematic
to folks certainly but we would just
want to know in terms of how that should
be addressed would it be that those
individuals would not be subject uh to
this type of enhancement or premium pay
um so i'm happy to take uh any questions
or answer any questions the only thing i
would offer answer from what i've heard
is representative avaloni when you
talked about salaried salaried folks as
representative edge and said generally
they're not you know they're they're
being paid their set salary regardless
of hours worked uh so it would not again
for the reason being we would not see
there being an enhancement here in those
types of situations
thank you mr ogden any
questions
seeing none thank you
oh excuse me sorry
representative avalani thank you mr
chairman thank you deputy commissioner
for being here today um
the question i have is if an employer
has two employees and they decide to do
the call-in game
i'm going to call in monday you call in
tuesday so we both you know all you have
to work three days out of our five days
to make a week's pay
what recourse would the employer have if
that happens
so the employer is then calling the
other one and saying they have to come
in they have to come in and cover that
shift because their friend called in and
can't come to work
as for the terms of what the proposed
legislation is they'd be entitled to the
enhanced payment thank you
are there any other questions
seeing none thank you mr argan
next going to call bruce burkey
thank you mr chairman and members of the
house labor committee for your record my
name is bruce berkey i'm with she
infinity capital group and i'm here on
behalf of
several clients
in opposition to
house bill 1053
we represent
ski new hampshire we represent white
mountain attractions we represent the
new hampshire lodging and restaurant
association
as well as the national federation of
independent business
and all four of those
entities are opposed to this bill
for
multiple reasons and primarily
speaking
of the first three
lodging restaurant
ski new hampshire and white mountain
attractions
they are the heart and soul of new
hampshire's tourism community
and in the tourism community as you may
know
there are
many factors that go into scheduling
and probably the biggest factor
is one that
i am not able to control the weather
and
the weather has a major impact on
scheduling of employees at these
different facilities throughout the
state of new hampshire
and it is
very
hectic at times to to get a full staff
and that is especially true today
with the
shortage of employees and so to have
the dictates of house bill 1053
um
laid upon them during
their process of ensuring that they have
the correct number of employees to
serve the
visiting public
it is really important that
they have that flexibility
i thought that um
the point that
the deputy commissioner made about
scheduling not being static
and that is
very very true in the tourism sector of
our state's business community
and so for these reasons we are in
opposition to the bill and i'd be happy
to address any questions you may have
thank you are there any questions for mr
burkey
uh representative mendel
yes thank you for your testimony here
today i wonder if the entities you
represent
on whether the proposed
legislation would actually
enhance
the workforce
staffing
circumstances by
attracting workers to our state by
virtue of this protection
well representative and i'm sorry i
didn't get your name
okay
um
the the circumstances under which these
businesses are operating in new
hampshire today are are very difficult
due to that shortage
and
any added costs
to their business operations
will have an impact on
hours offered
shifts offered to employees as well as
adding new jobs
and so with a finite amount of money
involved
they cannot
just you know provide for
time and a half situations or
new employ new employees
are there any other thank you mr cube
next we'll call
commissioner jasper
turn on the mic turn on the mic all
right sorry about that
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee i am
commissioner sean jasper of the
department of agriculture markets and
food my pleasure to be here committee i
served on as i was thinking about it i
think
10 years ago now
time time goes quickly when you're
having fun
i'm here in opposition to the to the
bill as it applies to to agriculture
which is also another
industry that's very dependent on the
weather
and
it can certainly speak to the fact that
agriculture does not tend to be
a overly profitable business in the
state of new hampshire most most people
farm because they they love it
doesn't necessarily bring them a lot of
financial
profit and certainly from year to year
that can be very difficult and when the
weather is is having to cancel works
schedules
or call people in at the last last
minute and so to actually have to tie
um
or pay time and a half
when you call somebody in when you
hadn't scheduled them because it's
either suddenly going to rain and you've
got to get the hay or vegetables or
other things and
there isn't the money
to back this up
so i would
ask you to consider this very carefully
the negative and it would definitely be
a negative impact
on agriculture if farmers suddenly had
to start paying time and a half every
time they had to call
workers in because of the
weather or possibly other emergencies
such as situations if you're milking
cows
and suddenly somebody calls out sick and
you've got to call somebody in at the
last last minute they're not going to
get any more money for that that milk
but those cows have to be milked on
on schedule
eggs have to be picked you know at a
certain time whatever it is agriculture
is on a schedule you can't simply say
well we'll wait till tomorrow when
people come in
so this this could have a very very
negative impact on agriculture in new
hampshire i'll leave it at that and be
glad to answer any questions
thank you are there any questions for
commissioner jasper
seeing none thank you thank you for your
time
next on the list i show uh david duray
from the bia
her members of the committee
for the record my name is dave gubay i'm
a senior vice president for public
policy with the business and industry
association we serve as new hampshire's
statewide chamber of commerce
and for the next three weeks i continue
to serve as interim president for the
association a position i am happy to
give up in early february as our new
president will be starting uh we are
here in opposition to this bill i don't
want to be repetitive and i know that
there are others behind me who will also
be opposing the bill i just want to
remind the committee that
employers in new hampshire
are having to deal with a couple of
different environments one is the
environment that has been created by the
coven 19 pandemic and that's affecting
employers in a couple of different ways
the first is it's infecting it's
affecting their revenue coming into
their places of business if you're a
restaurant owner or if you own a small
retail store if you
own some type of lodging
you're impacted by the fact that people
aren't traveling the way they were
pre-covered people aren't going out to
eat the way they were pre-covered people
aren't coming into uh bricks and mortar
retail stores the way they were
pre-coveted so your revenue is already
likely down
the second impact that
i think is even more directly related to
this bill with covet 19
is that most if not all employers have
implemented
different
pandemic related rules for coming into
the workplace
used to be pre-code if you had a sniffle
many people would just show up at work
that's not the case any longer employers
are saying if you have any type of
symptom
sniffles sore throat headache anything
stay home
and so
these types of
shortages of labor that the bill is
envisioning are actually quite common
now and completely out of the employer's
control
the other environment i want to remind
the committee that employers are having
to
acknowledge now is a significant
shortage of labor i moved to new
hampshire in 1990 so i'm not a lifelong
granite stater but i've been here a
while i've worked for the bia for 22
years i can't remember
a time where there was as significant a
labor shortage in the state as there is
now that employers are having to deal
with i have one manufacturing member
uh
uh in the monadnock region who says his
criteria for hiring people now is if
they can pass a drug test and fog a
mirror that's how desperate he is for
employees
so to get to a representative cahill's
would you believe question
yes i'd be willing to believe that there
may be employers out there that
may take punitive action if they request
an employee to come in for unscheduled
time but i would suggest that's an
employer that may be out of business
pretty soon because there are plenty of
job opportunities for employees who are
unhappy
in
their work situation i would suggest
that many employees
are happy to come into work if they're
able to to get the extra dollars so i
would ask that you find this bill in
expedient it's it's not good public
policy and it's especially bad at this
time in our history thank you mr chair
thank you mr
giuvet any questions representative
thank you mr chairman thank you mr duvet
for taking the question
do you find that your
employers are having to pay more per
employee now than they did pre-coded
there's no question that that is
happening
they're having you know the the question
of the minimum wage often comes up
before this committee
and uh as we all know that most if not
all employers around the state are
paying far higher than the minimum wage
before covet hit but they're certainly
having to pay more now in fact i often
get questions from
members
calling me asking
what are other employers doing how high
do we have to go what what is the market
right now so there is absolutely no
question that that's taking place i
would also add that many employers
recognize that calling someone in for
unscheduled work could be a burden
and if the individual says that they
absolutely can't well then they
absolutely can't but for those who say
they can
employers are often doing a lot and i'll
use the bia as an example we're a
relatively small shop we have eight uh
employees
but from time
with the exception of one person we're
all salaried exempt employees
but
we're occasionally called on to work on
what would normally be considered after
office hours
for those of you who've attended our
leadership summit you know that that
takes place on a sunday and staff is
expected to be there for those of you
who've attended our annual dinner that
takes place at night staff is expected
to be there my employer in order to
recognize that staff is sacrificing and
working at a time that they normally
wouldn't be provides compensation time
they'll say take take a half day off
fill out a slip say it's comp time for
the annual dinner and so and
employers are trying to find ways to to
work with employees to recognize they
are giving up on their time when they're
coming in for unscheduled work
any other further questions
seeing none thank you
next i'd like to call gina balkas
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee i'm gina balka ceo of the
granite state home health and hospice
association
our organization advocates for home care
and hospice agencies and palliative care
providers and the people they serve
we are opposed to house bill 1053
this bill would require employers to pay
time and a half for workers called into
work and not previously scheduled and
this is really untenable for home care
and hospice agencies
the patient census for home care and
hospice agencies changes daily
if more patients are discharged from
hospitals or referred by doctors the
census will go up
if a patient cared for at home is
readmitted to a hospital or dies on
hospice the census will decline
patient acuity also changes
their conditions may worsen and more
home visits may be needed
another example is when a person who's
enrolled in new hampshire's medicaid
waiver choices for independence program
or cfi
becomes eligible for more hours of care
the need for personal care services and
staff will increase
so because of this fluctuation in census
and acuity
agencies often cannot predict how many
workers they will need to schedule in
advance
also if scheduled staff
call out patients still need services so
other staff will be called in to replace
them
most of our part-time workers are per
diem employees who welcome the
flexibility of choosing the days they
work
but they also recognize and expect that
they may be asked to consider additional
shifts on short notice
so paying time and a half for
unscheduled employees called and torque
is not feasible because most home care
and hospice agencies depend on
government-funded reimbursement programs
such as medicare medicaid cfi or va
and the payments to agencies are set for
these programs and there is no ability
to obtain higher pay payments for higher
wages
and these programs barely cover the cost
of care now
house bill 1053 would cost would cause
labor costs to increase
and many of these agencies would likely
stop participating in some of these
government-funded programs
and so patients would go without care
i would urge the committee to find house
bill 1053 as an expedient to legislate
and i thank you for the opportunity to
speak
thank you are there any questions
uh
representative
mandeville mental i'm still learning
sorry thank you
thank you for coming in to testify i
just had one quick question you
mentioned in your testimony that um
employees with which you were familiar
appreciated the opportunity to um
select
certain hours and so forth and you added
that they understood that they
might have to consider that was the word
you use
extra shifts on short notice
in your experience or in your workplace
are those circumstances where the
employee has the option
to
consider and thus either accept or
reject
the extra shift or is there some
different approach generally
generally i believe that for especially
for per diem staff they're asked to come
in
and
they may decline
um
i don't think any employer can force an
employee to come in to work i guess
there could certainly be
an employer could say if you don't come
into work we're gonna fire you but that
is not my understanding of how it works
in home care or hospice because most of
the employees are per diem now the
deputy commissioner of labor said it
would likely not apply to per diem but i
don't see that in the statute
and so i think that would need to be
clarified
thank you
are there any further questions
see nuns thank you i do have copies of
my testimony for
you i have two cards left
gary abbott from the associated general
contractors
thank you chairman committee members for
the record my name's gary abbott i'm the
executive vice president of the
associated general contractors of new
hampshire
um i've our organization looked at this
bill i represent building and highway
contractors in the state
we looked at this bill and
we
really would want a definition of what
an employer's normal scheduling is
in construction if you're a plumber
you can get called out all the time for
different emergencies different days
the office if it's a big plumbing firm
can maybe doing scheduling the day
before
so
you might have to go you know be called
in on a weekend if some plumbing problem
happens
then we also have weather issues i
represent highway contractors
uh it's pretty clear in the contracts
that you know you don't pave in the rain
when it's really pouring or bad weather
a lot of times the companies will switch
the to working on a saturday or a
saturday and a sunday
that's kind of a normal procedure so
when it says the employers normally
scheduling
would they be in compliance or not in
compliance
it's also surprised that this bill
doesn't have a fiscal note
this could be very expensive
and not only for private employers but
for the state of new hampshire um a few
years ago we had a sinkhole on i-93
the d.o.t called in contractors to help
quickly fix that as that was opening up
we had to close the road here in concord
d.o.t employees had to be there
they worked into the night fixing that
repair everybody's proud that how
quickly they fixed that problem and
keeping the highway open
but how would they interpret this bill
everybody would be getting time and a
half because it wasn't a normal
this is very problematic so our
association opposes
house bill 1053 and i would agree with
some of the other previous speakers
i can tell you in my office
there hasn't been normal scheduling of
employees since covid started
employers like myself are very flexible
the old days of hourly from eight to
five o'clock are probably gone
there's a lot more flexibility
and with covid you have to be flexible
in case somebody comes down with
something it has to be out
you got to make those changes
every firm even whether it's a
construction firm is dealing with covet
and employees calling out this bill
would be very problematic to keeping the
operation going and so
again i would hope this committee would
vote itl on house bill 1053.
thank you mr abbott uh questions
representative avalani
thank you mr chairman thank you mr
edward for taking my question
in your line of work or your
people you represent line of work are
you noticing a shortage of products
that are causing a lot of rescheduling
oh we have we clearly have supply chain
issues it's probably one of the top
issues that we're discussing with state
agencies as far as trying to fulfill the
obligations of contracts
and getting products and
it clearly is an issue for the
construction industry
also
the previous question
was asked about
employees and finding employees very
very difficult in this market
contractors are doing everything in
their power to keep their employees and
and in i i know i represent some
companies that will tell me you come to
work for us you're gonna start at
twenty-five dollars an hour
thank you thank you for the follow-up
the uh
so if you had to factor in
this time and a half
for scheduling changes how would that
affect your contracts
well i think
this this is where the fiscal note comes
in
we might have a contract with the dot to
perform for a certain dollar amount it
clearly would affect that if the cost of
i got 40 an hour employees working on a
project the costs are going to
dramatically change depending on how
this is interpreted i think right now
i would make a plea to the labor
department that our normaling scheduled
and fluctuates all the time and this
wouldn't apply to us
that would be my first answer
thank you mr chairman
any further questions representative
huff
thank you mr chairman uh thank you mr
abbott for taking my question
i'm assuming um
and correct me if i'm wrong but a lot of
the folks that you might deal with are
union
uh no i would say 90 or open shop about
10 a union okay um
so
my question really kind of is about
union generally speaking my
understanding is unions
uh will have an agreement and they may
have a pay schedule
well what if you're at the top of that
pay schedule
well i i do have
i do uh at one part of my career i did
for the association negotiate union
agreements
and yes
uh
between labor and management they
negotiate those terms of whether it's
vacation days holidays how other days
work and time but that's negotiated and
i think this is where the problem with
any of these bills where
the employer's relationship with the
employees is either defined by a union
agreement even in open shop there's
usually a clear understanding how
flexible a company is with their
employees
we don't see big issues to require this
is i hope that answers your question but
you're right
i
this could affect those labor agreements
thank you
does anybody else have any questions
seeing none thank you mr thank you
last card i hold in my hand
curtis berry new hampshire retail
association
thank you mr chair members of the
committee good morning and it's great to
be back in committee
my name is
curtis barry here on behalf of the new
hampshire retail association
the association represents several
hundred members across new hampshire
that range from both the national major
chains to small main street shops and
everything in between
the associations opposed to this bill
and i'd like to give you a couple of
very specific retail examples of why
um
retailers of all sizes just like the
industries that you've heard from
previously this morning find it very
difficult to hire to find employees
there's one major chain
with one specific location in southern
new hampshire that for the holiday
season
spent the entire holiday season 45
positions short of their optimal
schedule to make matters worse at some
point in the beginning back in the fall
they had hired actually hired 30
individuals who did not show up for the
work presumably found another job and
didn't bother to tell anybody
at any given time over the last several
months they're
around 11 people short that are out
because they've tested positive for
coven
and this is on top of folks offering
incentives including that that
particular retailer
added uh hourly wage for weekend shifts
a 300 bonus for example for finishing
out the holiday season
and still they're finding it extremely
difficult if not impossible to find
employees um
the coveted situation with the 11
employees out on any given day
sort of exacerbates the impact of of
this bill
because
employers are having to scramble at the
last minute more than the typical cold
and flu season
in addition
many of the major members have apps for
the phone
where employees can
swap shifts
i want to take this day off when i'm
scheduled to
and they
post their shift with somebody else
another employee can willingly accept
the offer
this bill forces the employer then in
that case to pay them time and a half
when they willingly either at the
request of a fellow employee or the
employer
to come into work
the other retail specific example i'd
like to give you is
in the furniture and appliance sector
furniture stores are telling us uh and
you've probably heard from constituents
or other people that you know
um to place an order for a piece of
furniture nowadays
means a 12-month wait
um it's an awful long time
the customer puts a deposit down on a
piece of furniture at a set price and in
it in the interim
shipping costs and other costs could
increase and have increased
significantly
the furniture store at that point can't
go back to the customer and say geez my
costs have increased we're going to pass
this on to you it just doesn't work that
way the furniture store eats the
difference in cost so
i can foresee a situation where the
truck shows up there's a bunch of
furniture unloaded at the store they
want to get it delivered to the to the
customer as soon as possible and they
ask employees to come in and do that
this likely this provision would likely
put them in the red for that piece of
furniture and that's not a business
model that's going to be sustained for
very long so
uh for all of those reasons uh the
retail association opposes this bill and
asks you to find an integer to legislate
mr chair i'm happy to answer questions
to the best of my ability
thank you mr any questions
representative avilani
thank you mr chairman thank you for
being here today for our questions
um you mentioned the app where employees
can switch shifts that have already been
previously scheduled
upon reading this
provision
would time and a half apply to those
employees who have just switched out of
their schedules i believe it would yes
thank you thank you mr chairman
are there any other further questions
representative mannable
yes uh thank you for your testimony i i
understand the points you've made about
covet and uh the
shift
uh switching issues
the other two though i
i i struggle with a bit and so
my my question to you i guess is twofold
as to the
uh
concern about
the availability of workers which we all
are familiar with
wouldn't and given the mobility of
workers between this state and other
states
wouldn't this kind of a bill and this
one in particular
be viewed by the retail
industry
as
a means by which to attract workers to
come or stay here
and part b
in respect to the cost issue that you
raised at the end
wouldn't the idea of
predictability regarding
the cost to be incurred for
work of this sort be more able to be
factored into
a pricing mechanism
than a haphazard approach
thank you for the question
and i apologize my response earlier in
my testimony may not have been thorough
enough that i was trying to address your
earlier question from earlier in the
hearing
retailers are making every effort that
they can to provide a financial
incentive for people to come and work
and it's just not working so an
additional time and a half in this case
you know i think they're already
covering
um
in addition i would suggest that
whether it be a store owner or store
manager in their case knows what's
sustainable for their individual
situation
they're doing what's within their means
to attract employees
so i think they're already covering that
they know what is going to be necessary
but understand there's a balancing act
right
retailers sell items that are price
sensitive there's a decision you make
between buying item a or item b there's
a decision consumers make between buying
item a and not buying anything at all so
there's only so much that they can pass
on before affecting their sales so i
suggest they're already doing what they
can to attract the additional employees
thank you any other further questions
representative prout
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
do you know of any prohibition in
current law that would make an employer
that they couldn't offer as an
enticement for employees to come in for
work not previously scheduled time and a
half for that shift as part of the
request to come in thank you for the
question no no i don't and in fact i'm
aware in at least some industries that's
happening
thank you
any further questions
see none thank you mr berry thank you mr
jim
that's the last card uh i have is there
anybody else who wishes to speak for
against
hb
10 1053
seeing none we'll close the hearing on
that and i'll turn the gavel back to
chairman infant time
thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you
honorable members for welcoming and
welcoming me and to your committee
um it's been the first time i've been
before you in a long time
um so
this is a bill just a study committee i
know that uh there are
members who are understandably reticent
to do yet another study committee but
this has not been studied ever that i
could find
a study committee to
study the effects of high heat and
temperature
on employee working conditions and this
was something that i wanted
to look into because of my personal
experience with a
a whole host of different people i am a
a cdl licensed driver i have driven for
public transit for five years
and i also
have had my entire family has always
been basically in the restaurant
industry
so i've had a myriad of family members
friends neighbors and
bus passengers that i've just heard
stories from not because i had solicited
any particular stories about heat but
just they would come home or be on my
bus going home from work and talk about
the conditions that they had to work in
and honestly
over my life hearing these stories it's
horrifying it's something that you would
imagine
that would exist in another country or
in the you know maybe a hundred years
ago in a factory
stories of cooks that have to work over
open flames with no real ventilation in
the kitchen no air conditioning in their
kitchens
stories of people who have to do
do wood construction in these shops that
have no reasonable
air conditioning or proper ventilation
and from what i can under from what i
could dig up it's not something that
osha
has done a
thorough job of of covering
so i would just like to see in an
understanding that there's a lot of
factors here in terms of what would be
expected in a particular industry in
terms of what exact temperatures had an
effect at what humidity levels what kind
of airflow you would need for
for someone to remain healthy and being
able to actively do their job over hours
what kind of access to water they might
need
that this is something that just needs
more study than than i certainly can put
in as an individual it needs more
expertise than i have
but i'm i am uh
quite adamant and happy to talk at
length about the literal dozens dozens
of people that i've heard talk about
high heat working conditions over the
years
so
just want to know if we can study what
we can possibly do about this and i'm i
think that this is something that is
worth the study worth looking into and
that's that's really my testimony and
i'm happy to take questions
thank you representative
are there any questions
prove senator sullivan
thank you mr chairman
um thank you for taking my question
thank you for being here
um
there's um and mr chairman if i'm out of
order you'll be quick to tell me
but
there is bill hb 1304
which
is intended to
study the impact of outdoor working
conditions in heat and cold
it's not the same as what you're talking
about but it's awfully similar
um
and uh
i guess i'd just like to hear how you
think i mean
establishing two study committees would
i think be foolish
um
how could you see
dealing with the
needs of both of these bills
so thank you for the question obviously
when i submitted this idea to
ols and with the understanding that
typically the lawyers will notify you if
you're working on similar legislation as
another member but i was not notified so
i didn't realize that this other bill
was going in i'm very happy for these
two
study committees to be rolled into one
and
i think the wording would have to do
something about studying the effects of
both
high and low temperatures regardless of
indoor or outdoor situations
i wasn't going to call you out of order
this is labor we all get along
any other questions
for the
representative
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony it's the easiest yet i'll be
here all day so
thank you
we have uh ten more minutes folks
before your um
for our next
hearing just a few announcements if you
have not heard
the speaker has requested that we move
up by one week when we get
our bills in second committee our
financial
bills we only have two of them
and i have
scheduled both of them we've already
heard one of them
and we were getting the second one i
believe next time we meet we'll be
discussing it so we will have to execute
those and have them
out of our committee by february 10th
the speaker
intends to have a
house session
the week of the 15th of february
so we don't know where or what day of
the week
but at this point
it is my goal to have all of our bills
heard
by february 10th
thursday february 10th
some we will be executing
always be prepared
uh from the next
session on
to be here in person as best you can
if you cannot find a replacement for
yourself because we will be executing
bills
each of the next uh
two
labor committee sessions
or meetings
yes
i try to do them in groups
i was at a committee recently and
we all have different personalities in
how we run committees but boy you guys
lucky you're on that committee
um
this someone was asked to want to just
tell me as a presenting representative
that there was a typo and the chairman
requested that they
forming the phrase of a parliamentary
procedure or something it was just as
simple as typo on you know line three
um and then they were executing bills 15
minutes after they heard them which kind
of as a rule i don't think we should do
it's up to any chairman how they want to
do it so i'd like to give you as much
time in advance to let you know what
bills are coming up and which ones are
going to be exact if you look in your
calendar which should come out tomorrow
you'll see that heather and i were very
busy the last 24 hours trying to put all
these together let everyone know
what is going to be exact and when
i don't like pulling stuff out
i don't like pulling stuff out the last
minute you can have everyone has an
opportunity
you know just to say their piece there's
no gotcha stuff going on um
so any other questions of the chair at
this point
okay
uh yes representative
yes
that seemed to be the most consistent
now i know there's a few people
one of us needs to fly the friendly
skies so we're going to try to do some
things earlier in the day and other
people have obviously a number of you
have emailed me that you have interim
conflicts that you have to go
to a hearing present your bill speak on
behalf just like i did this morning
that's all fine and good i will try to
accommodate as much as possible if
someone here has a bill
and they cannot be there for a certain
day if there's an exec on that bill i
will not do that that day
unless i'm going to find a crunch with
time with the two
second committee bills which
is not going to happen
so just let me know i believe someone
this someone else has let me know
when they're not going to be around so
people have been pretty good about
letting me know
but it's very important i respect the
fact that some people don't want to come
into the committee room
um
but if you cannot on the 27th or the
third
at this point
please tell your party leader that you
need to be replaced
at least 24 hours in advance so we can
get someone here
because i don't want anyone to say well
we didn't get to vote we didn't know
there was going to be executive sessions
so
all right
okay
we got five minutes bathroom break
anything anyone wants to do
you're recognized to uh introduce your
bill
thank you mr chair again long time no
see everyone uh
thank you honorable members for the
record again my name is ellen reed i
represent rockingham 17 newmarket and
newfields
and this is uh
i've put this in before i believe in
2019 as part of a kind of a almost an
omnibus little combination
bill
um and at that time so this is just to
explain it this would be prohibiting the
use of a credit history check
in employment decisions for
most jobs um at that time it was almost
entire uh prohibition and there was a
lobbyist for the banking industry
that approached me and said we would be
fine with this if you exempted certain
types of positions that are kind of
fiscally sensitive
and i thought that was a perfectly
reasonable
compromise so this contains that
compromise um i am aware that there is a
lobbyist for
uh
representing a number of employer
clients that is here in opposition i did
just speak with him and i believe we can
work on clarifying language specifically
uh his concern primarily was that a
concern that this might not include
employees of contractors
so i am happy to work on an amendment to
clarify that that
provided those contractors those
positions where those contractor
employees would be
um
be used are sensitive positions that
they also be allowed to credit check
those employees
um but having said that
uh
i
i think that the
the reason this is necessary and i
realized we're currently in a labor
shortage and i was in the committee
office right here and overheard someone
say currently people are hiring anybody
who can i think pass a literacy test and
fog a mirror or something something to
that effect i understand that you know
right now uh this might not be a huge
concern for your everyday uh
employers and employees but it will
certainly be a concern again and the
issue is that we believe that we have um
a system
where
if you just
hunker down and work hard and save up
money you can get there
right we believe in that system that
kind of meritocracy
good hard work is is rewarded but the
problem with our current system if
you're credit checking employees who
happened to get into a situation where
they didn't have enough money to cover
their bills now they're stuck they're in
a catch-22 they can't get a job to pay
those bills
but you're
not allowing them to have a job in order
to pay those bills so they're stuck and
that isn't consistent with our ideals it
isn't consistent with our belief that
just enough hard work and hunkering down
um will will get someone where someone
where they need to go and i kind of want
to push back i think there's a bit of a
stigma when it comes to um
people that we call poor actually this
is a sociology term the unworthy poor
this stigma that
people with in this case bad credit
history um that they're just no good
they're just irresponsible lazy no good
people
and the truth of the matter is when you
actually look at individuals we're
talking about people who went through
divorce who had health concerns
who are going through perhaps a bad
economy right now
who
have had any number of issues happen to
them in their lives are there
irresponsible people in the world
absolutely but there's a whole bunch of
people through no moral feeling of
theirs who just happen to hit rough
times
and
what we're doing to those people is
cutting them out cutting their legs out
from under them and not enabling them to
work their way back up into a good
position
so again i'm happy to add any kind of
clarifying language to make sure any and
all sensitive positions are allowed to
credit check those employees
but um you know
i was security guard contracted
employees was brought up i'm happy to
work with that but i think for most
positions what we need to do is make
sure people are able give them a ladder
so that they can climb back up with that
i'm happy to take questions
thank you representative for any
questions for the presenter
representative cahill
you mr chair right thank you
representatives from new market
i've been on this committee for a while
and i've seen this bill a few times
and i'm always disappointed that it
doesn't pass
because i think it's i think it is
unreasonable to
limit someone's possibilities because of
some prior error that may not have been
an error at all maybe circumstances as
you mentioned medical bills
a divorce who you know maybe your spouse
has run up your credit and you have no
control over that and i've also learned
that there are many times the credit
reporting agencies have errors
and you could be i think i heard from a
previous sponsor of the bill that uh he
was in
in the lob testifying
and yet someone said he bought a tractor
in south carolina
oh yeah yeah i'm sorry
anyway so
do you uh do you feel as though
i see you've got most of the exceptions
covered
is the is there is there a
reason why i mean like have you heard of
examples where someone has passed a
credit check and you had somehow
embezzled i've seen town managers that
have embezzled is it a credit history
passing a credit history not again is it
not is it it isn't a guarantee that
something won't happen you won't have
gambling debts from uh
some other circumstance or some other
thing that happened that lead you to
pill for something from the drawer
uh
right
is that is that all
thank you thank you for the question my
honorable co-representative newmarket um
so right there is no guarantee in life
you are absolutely correct and certainly
people who happen to have a lot of money
and we can name any number of like news
stories on this issue who have a lot of
money and have a lot of great credit
um have been caught doing some really
awful things including financial things
or especially perhaps financial things
because a lot of times that's how they
got that money to begin with um but
uh you're right that there is no
guarantee
but again i i have put in those
exemptions and you know i also wanted to
point out yes i pointed out that people
may have ended up in bad credit because
of divorce or health crises or what have
you any even just a bad economy right
because if if we believe that people
with bad credit are simply you know no
good irresponsible people then why is it
that the worse the economy gets all of a
sudden there's more immoral people that
have bad credit no it's something that
impacts everybody regardless of their
morality or worthwhileness but also
young people right young people that's
an example of no credit
but how if they have if you credit check
all these positions
there's a real barrier to building up
good credit as a young person
so i understand that
perhaps an employer would make an
argument of well i would like to see
this person's moral character i want to
know that i'm hiring a responsible good
person but the point is is that this is
not reflective necessarily of their
responsibility and unless you're hiring
them for a sensitive position
that's really not nothing none of your
concern and you have to enable those
people to work their way up and out of
debt
um so thank you for the question
representative
any other questions
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um
so
where my head is at is that the process
of performing a credit check for the
employer is not free and i don't can't
see them
performing it for no reason so what can
you give me some examples of positions
that people are running credit checks
that don't fall into one of your
exemptions that you're what you're
trying to stop because i can't see you
know someone running a credit check for
a landscaping job or or something you
know there's no reason behind why the
employer wants the credit check i
just off the top of my head recently
heard of someone who was denied a job as
a sales job at a harley-davidson because
of a credit check
um was part of that job negotiating the
final price i mean it almost seems like
that would uh
you know
fit under the exemption of roman numeral
iii
my my understanding is which in which
case it shouldn't be a problem passing
this right but um but my understanding
is that while they had negotiation
skills they're limited to a certain
range in which there's a bottom line
that they can't go beneath so there's
that limitation and yes they were able
to negotiate the price but they didn't
weren't responsible for like taking the
person's money that was all done
um by the structure in the organization
so not not the person in charge of
actually doing the the money work
so thank you and apologies to the
chairman for getting that
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um
i see a a a small area here that i'm not
quite
sold on
and what that is is
this law
appears
to be telling an employer what they may
or may not be able to consider in hiring
an employee
now my question is is how are you going
to enforce that it's almost like
and i don't want to use this term
in the broad sense but it's almost like
thought police
you're saying to a an employer
do your due diligence to get the
employee that you want but don't think
about this
so how would you enforce that so it's
not thought police it's not don't think
it says shall use or request information
in the credit history so they can think
whatever they want but they can't
actually go after your credit report
okay stop follow-up i mean i mean to
further answer that question for example
we are in a um
a state where employers can
largely
employ or fire whoever they want so
technically if you come in and they
don't know your credit report but you
just for whatever reason you're dressed
you're hygiene you just look like you're
not a responsible person they cannot
hire you based on that obviously
right so it's not thought police is my
point uh no i'm i'm good
thank you thank you thank you
for representative cahill any other
first time around questions
representative cahill you recognized
thank you mr sharon a very brief one
this time
uh doesn't the question of
doing a
credit history doesn't that sort of go
to the
disdain for interfering in people's
privacy their financial
records and
who knows what else they would learn if
uh studying your credit history thank
you so much for the question that is a
point that i failed to mention in my
testimony and had thought to mention
originally that there is a certain
expected level of privacy for example if
my bedroom habits are you know
considered private and they and those
habits don't impact
a potential job that i might be filling
it would we would all consider extremely
invasive for an employer to somehow get
an official record of what i might be
interested in the bedroom right so that
would be entirely invasive of my privacy
and have nothing to do with the job
so
likewise they your potential employer
could find out any number of whatever
habits or interests or whatever you
might have by looking at a credit report
so yes it's invasive if it has the point
is it have if it has nothing to do with
the job that you're being hired for then
it should be none of their business and
it shouldn't be considered because you
have a right to build yourself up and
save up money work hard and get out of
debt
any additional questions for the
presenter
i think that shut it down
thank you
before i call
bruce berkey
to tell us why they have to add the
nuclear regulatory people i'm going to
call rudy ogden from the department of
labor
thank you chairman for the record rudy
ogden deputy commissioner department of
labor um just in reviewing this
legislation the one question we have as
was mentioned earlier uh bills or bills
like this have come up several times so
in a generalized sense we're aware of
the intent and what uh is being looked
for but relative to lines 14 and 15 um
the department would just seek
additional guidance or clarification the
exception that says an employer has a
bona fide purpose for requesting or
using information
i believe the intent may be to be
incredibly broad with that language but
i would just point out that from an
administration or an ongoing
administration standpoint we would just
be looking for
um
if an employer runs a credit check and
they say well i believe that is a
indication of responsibility
would it be the department then saying
no that's not a valid reason that's not
a bona fide reason
again i think i just put it out there as
something where if this was passed we
would just want to be clear that we see
that as being very broad so it might be
beneficial to uh tailor that a little
bit or more narrow it so that for
purposes of actual intent
that could be met happy to take any
questions
thank you mr agnes nice to see you again
we've talked a lot in the telephone but
it's nice to see you after probably over
a year
any questions for representative avaloni
you're recognized
thank you mr chairman thank you deputy
commissioner
14 or 15 were questioned as well but
most employers
need a release from the employee or
potential employee to have their credit
check have a background check to have
anything
checked um so they would be
aware that their credit
could be a deciding factor in their job
would you
agree with that
if they're complying with uh what they
should be then yes there should be some
acknowledgement or notice that the
credit check is going to happen
thank you thank you mr chairman
you're welcome
representative cahill
thank you mr chair and uh thank you
jeffy ogden
the question was asked earlier about
enforcement would this be handled in the
way of other claims that
a person who
applied for a position and came to the
they were
asked to ask to sign the release
providing the consent for the
credit check after this had passed
would that be a violation or something
that would be brought to the
department's attention
for correction
representative cahill thank you for the
question yes this is uh from the
intended legislation being placed in rsa
275 protective legislation uh it would
be subject to our other enforcement
actions namely if there was a violation
of this or suggestion of a violation of
this we would look into whether or not
it happened or more likely than not
happened
there would be the probably an initial
warning because the warning statute
would call for a warning to the employer
of our suggestion that there's a
violation here if it's not corrected
there could be fines
resultant from the action or inaction
thank you very much
any other questions for the
deputy commissioner
seeing on thank you very much sir
now i wanted to call on rep
on
mr berkey
sorry to mess with you good morning
bruce i didn't mean to
mr chairman it's always a pleasure to
interact with you
for your record uh my name is bruce
berkey i'm a lobbyist with sheen fitting
capital group and we represent nextera
energy which is the majority owner of
seabrook station in seabrook new
hampshire
they own approximately 89
of the
of the facility
and we are here today
in opposition to house bill 1385.
i am the unnamed lobbyist that
representative reed spoke with we had a
nice conversation about uh some of our
concerns
and in particular
um there are two
um concerns that are
bright um
and there perhaps are others
uh
at the facility there is a a security
force that works um to
keep that facility
uh tight and safe and secure
and they are
contractors they are not employees of
nextera energy
next their energy contracts with a
company to provide that service
and so
with the responsibility that next server
energy has in overseeing the facility
um there'd be a strong potential that
there would be a need for
the
for them to have access to
credit reports for
the employees of that contractor
the second example
is that every 18 months seawork station
goes uh shuts down and goes through
about a 30-day refueling process
for the for the
rods that
create the energy at the at the plant
and during that process there are
in the neighborhood of 500 additional
employees there are generally about 600
employees at the station
year round
but during the refueling process there
are an additional 500 or so
employees
and they're not employees of next-door
energy
they are employees of contractors who
come on site
who have specialties
these people are from all across the
country
they're not just new hampshire
they they they go from
a nuclear power plant to nuclear power
plant to nuclear power plant all across
the country performing these services
and it's it's been a boon for the uh
rental real estate market um in in the
seacoast because of the
uh the time of year that they come in
they come in generally around april or
in the october november time frame when
those rental car cottages are
empty
so
those employees those contractors
employees of those contractors
also need to
have their credit
reports available to nextera energy
because the ultimate responsibility for
that site is next to our energy
so uh representative reed and i spoke
and about the possibility of developing
some language
um i'd be happy to work with her or with
the committee or both
and with that i'd be
happy to try and answer any questions
you may have
thank you mr burke any questions
representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman um thank you mr
berkey for your testimony
you brought up something that over the
years i haven't heard discussed before
so i'll ask you for your thoughts in a
more general sense even though you're
you're talking about a very specific
industry
so
someone works primarily in another state
and
that state doesn't have these
prohibitions so they have had and this
is very broadly it's is related to
hiring but also termination promotion
demotion discipline compensation
it's in its credit checks
in anything to do with employment
so a person works in another state where
this is done as a matter of course now
they come and are involved in a project
in new hampshire where they have some
kind of
nexus with a new hampshire employer
from what you said it would seem like
this could create a
an instant problem
because the law didn't apply until the
moment it suddenly does
any
thoughts
on that in the more general sense
thank you representative seaworth
that's a great question and and one that
i have not sort of mapped out as to how
it would be addressed but
um
certainly nexter energy would
you know if they have access to that
information
uh can go to the employer of that
contractor
or to that business that is the
to you know air concerns
but it would create a very confusing
process because of the
interstate nature of the
activity
representative cahill
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
berkey
um
so am i correct in that the federal
regulations that you know
cover nuclear facilities don't refer to
contract workers
that was my understanding
thank
you representative mandeville
uh yes thank you uh mr berkey for your
testimony i um
um i understand you're concerned about
contractors and you've said you'd be
willing to talk to
the bill's proponent about that
and you may have heard deputy ogden's
uh point about um
uh sub paragraph four and the bona fide
purpose i wonder if your client
would feel that some of its concerns
would be addressed if there were some
sort of proactive opportunity set forth
in the bill
that would allow
prospectively a bona fide purpose to be
identified and approved by the labor
department
thank you representative mandeville
that's a
a good question um
i would agree with deputy commissioner
ogden that the
language is a little broad
in some instances we might like it to be
broad
um but
certainly
you know any language in any law that
does not have four crisp corners
brings in the lawyers and and i'm sure
that's a concern of the departments and
it would certainly be a concern of
next-door energies
so i would um
you know i would endeavor
myself representative reid this
committee
to
try and crisp that up a little bit yes
thank you
any other questions for
mr berkey
seeing on thank you very much thank you
i do not have any additional pink cards
for uh
hospital 1385 do we have anyone in the
audience that has not signed up that
would like to speak
sing none close a hearing on house bill
and in three or four minutes we will
start
on 12 51.
do we still have the
the books are there the laws
these i've memorized them all
the reason i bring this up if you have
looked at the next bill in front of us
it references
rsa 279 20 colon 22 and 279 colon 21.
um
so
just want to make sure i have it out for
everyone in case they have any questions
related to what that means
uh 279 22
colon 22a because that's to do with high
school students and um
and
minimum wage for
that
so
and so the exceptions
thank you
wow
this is so old
holy mackerel
this is 2010.
well this is close to useless
well usually they had a little tape or
that they chuck in here you know they
just kind of
i oh sorry will
uh i do not have
i would like to open
the hearing on house bill 1251
i do not have any pink cards at this
point
but i see one cometh
just handed to me
do i have any of the sponsors
okay
chris schultz
no worries we're good
okay well we we do have a little bit of
time here so
you can
slow down get your get your
either side either side or both whatever
yeah i'll tell them a second just
give us a few minutes representative to
get these all handed out to everybody
and then um we'll
commence
i apologize if i don't get this right
representative estelle
oh
no someone sent it in so i just
it says your last name is spelled
i-s-t-e-l so that's why i said what i
said
oh
okay well we'll get to you in a moment
representative you're recognized to
present your bill
representative could you yeah there you
go
i just came from criminal justice too i
should know this
all right there we better there we are
um i'm going to start and say thank you
again because i appreciate you all being
here and thank you for your service and
attention today house bill 1251 is a
simple bill designed to allow new
hampshire's tipped wage workers
and disabled workers access to nothing
more than minimum wage which is 7.25
the new hampshire sub minimum wage
reserved for tipped workers
is now frozen at 3.37
until last year subminimum wage was
coupled with the minimum wage at 45
percent of minimum wage
we know that new hampshire defaults to
the federal minimum wage of 7.25 cents
per hour
the bill passed last year eliminated
this coupling
and freezes sub-minimum wages for tipped
employees at three dollars and 27 cents
per hour
even if the federal minimum wage rises
under current law any restaurant hotel
motel inn cabin or ballroom employee who
receives more than 30 a month in tips
may be paid by their employer at 45
percent of the current 7.25 an hour
which amounts to 327 and again that's
now frozen
new hampshire workers are again at a
disadvantage when compared to wages in
our neighboring states
minimum wage for tipped workers in our
neighboring states are massachusetts at
six dollars and fifteen cents per hour
maine is six dollars and 38 cents per
hour
and vermont is six dollars and 28 cents
per hour
you may not think of tipping as a legacy
of slavery but it has far more
racialized history than most americans
realize
tipping originated in feudal europe and
was imported to the united states by
american travelers eager to seem
sophisticated
the practice spread throughout the
country
and after the civil war as u.s employers
largely in the hospitality sector looked
for ways to avoid paying formerly
enslaved workers
one of the most notorious examples comes
from the pullman company which hired
newly freed african-american men as
porters
rather than paying them a real wage
pullman provided the porters with just a
meager pittance forcing them to rely on
tips from their white clientele for most
of their pay
tipping further entrenched a unique and
often racialized class structure in
service jobs in which workers must
please both customer and employer to
earn anything at all
a journalist quoted in kerry seagrave's
2009 book tipping an american social
history of gratuities
wrote in 1902 he was embarrassed to
offer a tip to a white man
he wrote tips go with civility and no
man who is a voter in this country
is in the least justified in being in
service
the immorality of paying an insufficient
wage to workers who were
who then were forced to rely on tips was
acknowledged at the time
in his popular 1916 anti-tipping study
the itching palm writer william scott
described tipping
as an aristocratic custom that went
against american ideals
the relation of a man giving a tip and a
man accepting it is as undemocratic as
the relation of master and slave scott
wrote
a citizen in a republic ought to stand
shoulder to shoulder with every other
citizen with no thought of cringing
without an assumption of superiority
or an acknowledgment of inferiority
when the department of labor conducted
an unusual sweep
of 9 000 full-service restaurants
between 2010
and 2012
they found that 84 percent had violated
the sub-minimum wage system
in order to chase after those lost wages
workers have to file complaints with the
department of labor
that takes time and money and that is
something a tipped worker who has
missing wages
already doesn't have
there are states that have eliminated
the tipped wage altogether
like oregon and washington
and my colleague representative schultz
will be able to speak to you more about
that
in conclusion i urge the committee to
right the wrong done to our tipped and
disabled workers and recommend that
house bill 1251 ought to pass
thank you very much i've provided you um
with some
um
some research data
and uh which you are i'm not going to go
through it because we're all you know
you are all able to read it and
you can do that at a time that's most
convenient for you but there's some
information there and the references to
where it came from are printed on the
sides of the pages
thank you representative any questions
for the presenter representative
seaworth
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for introducing your bill
several times during your testimony you
mentioned disabled workers and i'm
looking at the language of your bill
here
it seems that the
individual with a disability is already
prohibited in current language
and by striking that you're not
changing anything relative to disabled
workers am i misinterpreting the bill
you you have not
thank you
all right now you got me confused
actually and well
representative schultz is going to speak
more to that representative seaworth we
this committee did pass a law correct
which we can no longer provide a
lower than minimum wage for disability
so what was your question about why that
was crossed out
and the
what i was questioning i i recall
working on that legislation too
i was questioning the statement and the
testimony that this would
provide
additional wages to disabled workers
which
i understood not to be the case and i
wanted to make sure i wasn't
misunderstanding the intent of this
language
thank you mr great any other questions
seeing none thank you very much
representative chris schultz
who recognized to speak
thank you mr chair and committee
and i hope you'll stay here too so as i
was saying
i'm a representative from concord i'm
working on wage issues i most recently
worked for the one fair wage campaign
where representative alt shiller and i
also were working on well actually the
federal
only the federal raise the wage act
which does include a provision about
disabilities but 10 states new hampshire
being the first did probably with the
work here
of many of you uh did get rid of that
sub minimum wage for workers with
disabilities so sorry for that confusion
but
on the federal work that we were doing
that is not the case federally
um
so i no longer work for one fair wage
but i didn't want it to seem like
there was an impropriety to my
sponsoring this which is
why
representative altschiller is a sponsor
and i have since been laid off by said
organization
which is fine um
because i we have been
eager to see wage justice for some time
and as she mentioned uh there are seven
states in the country that we can look
to to say how does this work how does
this impact the marketplace how does
this impact
competition
how does this impact the back of the
house at a restaurant
as well as the front of the house which
i know has been a concern for some
workers
but in those states
restaurants have thrived profits have
gone up
we know this because
folks have brought it up on their
investor calls for companies like darden
for example
soon after california eliminated the
subminimum wage category
for workers wages uh darden said i'm
surprised the ceo of darden to the to
the shareholders uh that he was
surprised that actually
the restaurants in the states where
there where the sub minimum wage had
been eliminated we're doing better
and that is in part because you know
it's sort of that old uh henry ford
saying you know you want to pay workers
well enough so they could buy the cars
well you want to pay your workers well
enough so they can eat at your
restaurant i mean that is a piece of it
in new hampshire of course
that is a significant portion of our
workplace we are a tourist state
um we
uh have also the highest percentage of
women in tipped wage jobs
in the country
it's somewhere around 75 78 percent
nationally that average is in the 60s
so
predominant business here that is
predominantly filled by women
is a concern and
we have information about the families
on one piece of this and i can provide
more on this and the regular minimum
wage but it does disproportionately hurt
families mothers with children
um so much so as we discussed with the
regular minimum wage
that uh
and it's still to me i think should be a
bipartisan concern
that workers who earn so low that they
have to go on public assistance which
means we the taxpayers we the property
taxpayers or however you pay your taxes
subsidize the wages of those companies
and i think for maybe different reasons
for the same reason that doesn't seem
right you know that any worker that's
working full-time in new hampshire one
of the wealthiest states the wealthiest
country on earth
that just
that doesn't make any sense to me so i'm
hoping this bill and the tabled minimum
wage bill we can perhaps find some
common ground
on that piece i don't want to
i definitely want to acknowledge that
because i think there is some room for
some bipartisan action
that would actually
increa increase
the income of all
granite staters overall and increase the
wealth in general and all the other
great things that happen when you
prosper as a state
um
okay you mentioned that
i also want to say there was a rumor
because
the
new hampshire lodging and restaurant
association
is a formidable organization um i
actually know the folks
that uh are involved with that
organization and the restaurant owner
that's prominent
i have a good relationship with him
we've worked together on some
immigration
[Music]
laws uh gosh 12 years ago at this point
but one of the things that they say is
that servers don't want this
their tips will go down
that actually is not the case
um
in fact
uh their wages will go up
and um
that's important to understand
you will also hear that servers don't
want this and we have done a survey that
i can provide to you and i don't know i
don't remember if it's
quoted on here but um
the raise the wage coalition which is
mostly all volunteer has done
a survey
of the workers in this industry and in
fact the over industry
would like a raise
um
and i think it's compelling when you see
the signs
that
many workers are needed in a number of
jobs the dunkin donuts near me which is
across the street from the walmart on
loudoun road that's my district
their signs recruiting workers
says starting wage fifteen dollars with
tips on top
i think if it's good enough for dunkin
donuts
it should be good enough for our entire
workforce
it levels the playing field um
there are a lot of other things i could
say about this and i'm happy to provide
more information as we can and
answer any questions that you have
thank you for your testimony any
questions for the presenter
seeing none thank you very much thank
you mr chair
next up representative klein knight
oh
thank you chairman of labor and thank
you to the committee
for hearing
our testimony today for the record i'm
representative nicole klein knight of
manchester district
11 for hillsboro county
i come before you today
not just as a sponsor but as a
service industry worker
as you know the long hours of the
legislature and
the weird schedule that we promote from
a week to week basis
is hard on a young person to get a
normal full-time job
so sometimes to make ends meet i will
work in restaurants in the industry
and
i have to say relying on other people
for baseline income
is
at best
it's
it's unreliable
if you don't get tipped
and it's slow because of covid
you make three dollars for a whole hour
and i'm expected to
serve well 325
i'm expected to serve and live and fight
for the people of the state along with
other people
that also work in this industry
how do you expect us to pay our rent and
pay for food and pay for gas
on
such
mere
scrappings
there's been times where the business
owner
doesn't have
their
stuff together to put it in a nice term
they don't
stock their shelves they don't go out
before
opening and they don't
get supplies needed so they're
constantly out of something if you were
a customer to order something and it's
out
who do you take that out on
you take it out on the server if your
food's late who do you take that out on
the cook or the server
there's things that are out of our
control
but yet as the face of the industry
we suffer the brunt of
the consequences
now
i don't know about you but
that doesn't seem fair to me
so at least a bare minimum this would
provide a fighting chance for
people like me and
i represent
a small population but
a large population of service industry
workers who have really suffered during
this time
and the least we could do if they're
relying on tips to survive and there's
nobody coming into a restaurant or the
restaurant owner is failing them to
provide
a well-run business
these people suffer
they
they can't feed their kids
they run the risk of
homelessness and it
it goes on and on
so for that for all those reasons of
relying on other people
to pay your living wage
i urge you to please consider this is a
small ask to meet the federal minimum
standard of ought to pass thank you so
much for your time
thank you representative are you going
to introduce your your guest
oh yes this is well she actually um
spoke she signed up to speak to testify
so i just didn't know if she all right
we'll ask
we'll see if we have any questions here
of the members of you and then
um is
libby is that her name okay they will
call libby in a moment are there any
questions for the representative knight
representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for your testimony
in your testimony if i understood it you
implied that you have
on at least one occasion been paid
including tips less than the minimum
wage which is illegal under both federal
and state law is
was that the case and if so did you take
any action under the current law to
rectify that situation
um thank you for your question
representative i i'm concerned uh that
do you not know what the sub minimum
wage is for tipped workers
i am well informed about the law in this
state
okay but it's under seven dollars
so i'm confused if you could clarify
i i believe the minimum wage for tipped
is two dollars and nineteen
cents federal
new hampshire's 325.
and what i'm referring to if i may
mr chairman is that
both federal and state law requires that
all employees including tipped employees
be paid the federal minimum
an employer may take as credit against
that minimum any tipped wage
above
and there are two different levels
there's the lower level for federal and
a higher level for state
but at no time may the total wage be
less than the
minimum wage for all employees
and that's what i was referring to
the testimony seem to be saying there
are employees who who don't honor that
who pay less than
the absolute minimum wage
even when
adding in the tipped amounts
and
if that if that is this representative's
experience
i'm wondering if
she took further action
considering it was a violation of the
law
thank you for your question actually um
there have been times where the business
owners were struggling and i hadn't been
paid actually for weeks on end but
because
i wanted the my community to be
successful and i care about small
business owners
i decided to keep it to myself but after
a certain period of time i actually did
reach out to the labor board so thank
you
but this is a real concern and i'm just
one person it happens all the time all
across the state
are there any other questions for
representative knight
seeing none thank you for your testimony
i now call libby johnson from pelham
you're recognized to speak
um thank you um so i have friends that
do not necessarily have stable living
conditions
and they need to take these jobs to help
provide for themselves for like food
clothing school books etc
um
so
raising like the sub
minimum would really help them out if
they don't get any tips
that's all thank you
thank you for testifying
um
any questions for
i'll not be taking any questions any
questions for ms johnson
thank you for testifying i know it can
be nervous the first time thank you
representative you're standing looking
at me go ahead
thank you
i have uh two pink cards uh left claudia
istel and then i'll have to like to
speak with
commissioner
ogden
thank you welcome to the labor
committee good morning thank you
mr chairperson and the committee i'm
claudia estelle i live in acworth
i'm representing myself
[Music]
wage issues are something that are
important to me is a moral issue
and also as a practical issue i have
written testimony that i submitted
online and i don't want to waste your
time repeating myself
or and
particularly on things that you've
already heard
but our two points i'd like to bring up
please are
that um
i think that tipped wage workers often
are subject to harassment
and to discrimination
if the if your
server is
younger or more attractive people are
more likely to pay to leave a larger
chip
which is not necessarily fair to the
worker
and particularly during covid um
tipped workers are often submitted to a
lot of harassment it's kind of like oh
take down your mask i want to be able to
see what you look like and see whether
you're smiling or not just so i can
determine what your tip is going to be
um
and then the other thing is is that
we have uh
in this state we have a big problem with
a worker shortage
a lot of that is not just a purview of
your committee um there's a affordable
housing shortage there's a lack of
affordable daycare
but
being able to pay people appropriately
is something that you
you can make a difference on by passing
this bill and i would encourage you to
do that thank you
thank you for your testimony do you have
any
questions for the presenter
seeing none thank you very much
like to call deputy commissioner rudy
ogden please
good afternoon rudy ogden deputy
commissioner uh department of labor just
happy to answer any questions uh that
folks have the one thing i did want to
clarify
is relative to individuals with
disabilities they're uh you are correct
uh members who spoke to that law having
been changed some time ago there is
still an allowance for individuals with
disabilities to be paid at a sub-minimum
rate if they're part of a training
or rehabilitation program so there is
still that allowance but in a
generalized sense that was changed a
couple years ago so i just wanted to
clarify on that point happy to answer
any other questions
i do have a question for you
in this
bill line six it references rsa 279
colon
a a
high school and post-secondary student
workers with disabilities now i'm
looking at
this is rsa has annotated up to i guess
2021.
is that still
in our law
is this still applicable 22 aaa is still
applicable okay and it talks about being
able to
petition
the commissioner
to request a
a minimum wage for high school students
or post secondary students correct
correct does anyone ever do that
yes
could you give us an example of
one in the last uh
year or so so typically we would refer
to that as school to work and that does
come up in the context of internships
quite often there will be employers who
through an arrangement with a college
they will say that um
this employee this student might work
um
they're not really paying them sub
minimum there are some unpaid
internships though that work through
that process
so it comes up it does come up quite
often in the context of internships
and one last question
other than the internships
have you seen any proposals in the last
two years that outline
a
sub-minimum wage of say
dollars
or six dollars or something else other
than
you know these unpaid internship type
things off the top of my head no
all right thank you very much
representative cahill
thank you mr chair and thank you deputy
ogden
there was
testimony
earlier about situations where
the the server has not been paid
the appropriate you know the full
minimum wage based on their
uh
on their sub minimum and the tips
uh a nice i see that this is something
that a person can do that if they make
thirty 30 a month which seems like very
other low but do you have people
reporting such such situations
and might that be
that they don't happen or that they are
as
intimidated about reporting being you
know shorted on their on their wages
i would say that this most often when it
does come up it's not involving a
scenario in which the employer is just
paying the sub minimum it's when the
employer is not paying at all so if you
have an employer that's uh just not
doing anything right there are instances
in which they're not paying their
servers the sub minimum rate
thank you
arizona representative avaloni
thank you mr chairman thank you again
deputy commissioner um
this would repeal
27921 the entire section
is that my understanding
correct our understanding of this
legislation is that it's replacing 21
the existing statute that sets forth the
subminimum rate for tipped workers
um and tracks to the federal uh minimum
wage overall it's replacing it with the
language here correct
and follow mr chairman follow up um one
of these limitations says it doesn't
apply to outside salesmen and things
like that so would salesmen that are
commissioned or anything like that be
having now having to be paid minimum
wage even if they're not bringing in any
business
i do think you'd have to look at the
other exceptions that are set forth in
21 for purposes of this
well but they're being repealed
everything that whole sections being
yeah so i think it would have to be
looked at the effects of that i think
that likely those are all affected
one more yes please
thank you mr chairman
and 22 aaa
i know you guys went through that about
high school and post-secondary workers
how about for um
like work study or if you're in a trade
and you're working to trade
like you're being an electrician in your
off week of school and things like that
they're gonna be required to be paying
these people
minimum wage now
if unless they have an exemption
i just want to make sure i'm clear on
that
so again my understanding of this
legislation is it says notwithstanding
or accept as provided so i believe it
allows what's happening in 22a to
continue to happen
so if you had those requests for
internships or other opportunities where
there's a learning and experience
component to it which again we most
often call school to work but there's
other arrangements like that those and
our understanding would still be allowed
see on line six where it says accept as
provided in rsa 279 22a
okay
thank you mr chairman thank you deputy
commissioner
any questions for the commissioner to my
right
to my left representative mandeville yes
thank you mr chairman uh thank you
deputy ogden um
representative seaworth referred
previously to
the current 279 21
relative to the provision that
the employer needs to make up a
difference between
the
amount of tips received and the minimum
wage if if the former falls short
in that respect
the current 279 21 says
if such an employee show and such an
employee includes restaurant workers for
example among others if such an employee
shows to the satisfaction of the
commissioner that the actual amount of
wages received at the end of each pay
period
did not equal the minimum wage for all
hours worked the employer shall pay the
employee the difference to guarantee the
federal statutory minimum wage
could you give us a sense of the
experience in
the department
regarding
those issues raised proof offered
decisions made in other words give us a
sense of
how this statutory provision
happens as as
you know in the daily life of the
department so i think as i referenced
earlier most often when we run into
instances here it's not a matter of
where the employer
is only paying 327 and then not doing
the truing up it's most often that the
employer is paying nothing so it's the
employers having financial problems or
for whatever reason
they're just paying nothing so most
often that is how it's come up oddly
enough the other instance in which it's
come up as a problem particular to this
statute is if you do the math if you
actually do the division of it it's like
three the the minimum or sub-minimum
rate should be 326 with like trailing
decimal we have had employers who are
only paying 326. of course you can't pay
fractions of a cent so they should be
paying 327. so i'm not trying to get
lost in the weeds but if you're actually
asking how have we interacted with this
statute it's most often saying you're
not paying 326 and running decimal you
should be paying 327 or it's they're
paying nothing
we don't we have not had many instances
in which the the
the instance is i didn't make enough
tips to make hole and my employer only
paid me that it's that i didn't make
enough tips and my employer paid me
nothing or my employer paid me nothing
and i still made tips so that's most
often how it's come up or been dealt
with
follow-up
do you think that's because those
latter circumstances don't exist or they
just
are difficult for employees to bring to
the commissioner
well i i couldn't say i mean
representative cahill brought up this
idea of folks being intimidated to reach
out sadly i can't speak to the fact if
there's folks who are too intimidated to
come forward i'm not aware of that
again my generalized understanding our
inspections that we've done uh we do a
lot of inspections of restaurants and
hospitalities we typically are not
seeing the we're seeing no payment or
we're seeing them pay
and then the truing up is happening and
if the place is actually functional
usually the tips are enough because
again the minimum wage is not that high
i think was said earlier the minimum
wage
is pretty low so between the 3 27 and
tips
that oftentimes is happening if the
place is not functional at all or is
just failing or if there's other things
going on that's i think when it comes up
and those are the instances in which
then no payment is typically happening
any other questions for the deputy
commissioner
cena thank you very much
representative schultz i take uh a point
of reading body language and and you
shook your head a number of times so if
you
so if you would like to make a brief
comment uh before we break for lunch um
you may
i'm a bad poker player i do
wear my feelings honestly i will say
what i know for sure
is too many workers especially tipped
wage workers don't know their rights
they believe their hourly wage is only
the 3 27.
uh
they realize they get tips if they don't
make
7 25 an hour which is our federal
minimum wage
there are multiple ways you can account
by hour
and i'm certain that it doesn't always
work out that way it's complicated it's
difficult
honestly the the easiest way to fix this
is to get rid of the subminimum wage
category
the second thing i'll say and again i
really appreciate you calling me back up
because i wouldn't have asked for this
the intent of this bill is specifically
about the sub-minimum wage category
when authoring this bill with uh
tony dean tangelino i believe that's how
you pronounce his last name who writes
most all the labor bills
um i did ask about the
sales by commission
the special category that
licensed workers like hairdressers who
rent a booth and essentially they're on
commission as well
that is a whole other segment of the law
i'm pretty sure
i will double check
but that was not intended to be affected
by this bill
this was specifically targeting
subminimum wages
um
as i understand it currently only
affects and it called it used to call
out specific i think that y'all got rid
of this last year when you changed how
wages were paid instead of a percentage
to go to a specific number but it
included a number of tipped wage worker
categories you know caddies
busboys
you know that sort of thing
um sky caps um
and the student portion
and i also just happen to know like
college work study programs
is affected by federal law it is a
specific
federally aided program
and minimum wage applies
to that but rarely do students make that
i was a poor college student who made
that
so
i hope that's helpful no thank you but
it is the intention because i heard your
concerns the intention isn't to affect
any of the
um
any of those categories
that aren't
under traditional wage categories like
commissions and rentals of booths and
those are another category of worker i'm
pretty sure at least that was the
intention
of the bill
representative sullivan you have a
question
more of a comment just to clarify what
the representative is
is saying
um
279 colon 21 is a fairly substantial
piece of legislation
and it appears that this
this bill replaces all of 279 21 with
one sentence okay
um if it was if that was not the intent
then i would suggest that this bill does
not represent your intent
okay um so i
need some study
unless the committee likes it as it is i
you know
it's your bill at this point i you know
i've stated our intent
all right
thank you seeing no other oh i'm sorry
representative abelani
yes please thank you representative
representative
mind
mr chair i believe you demoted the
deputy commissioner to representative oh
sorry because i'm just
so used to it uh deputy
commissioner my apologies
for the demotion no no worries at all
thank you mr chairman thank you
deputy commissioner for coming back up
um
i just want to clarify representative
sullivan brought it up i brought it up
this replaces the entirety of 279 21
including all the subsections with one
sentence
correct and i apologize if i wasn't
clear our reading of this would be that
all of those things would have to looked
at as being taken
off the table
thank you very much thank you mr
chairman thank you for coming back up
i see no other hands
uh
but
there's a rarity oh
um it is uh
i'm closing the hearing
on hospital 1251 we have 45 minutes for
lunch i will be here if anyone has any
questions i'll see you back here at one
o'clock
he's been trying to run the restaurant
private parties
so people are still going in there
they're shut down
by the state but he has
parties there
so
and
yes
when she said that well i didn't want to
get him into trouble
so she's not getting paid for
those months
and then she comes as well because my
minimum wage is
and
you kind of
welcome back everybody
i'm going to open the hearing well let
me get my sorry let me put my cards in
order here sorry guys
abbott your last
just kidding
opening the hearing on house bill 1094
and and call ellen reed as prime sponsor
to testify on behalf of your bill
welcome back
once again and for the final time today
thank you mr chair and thank you
honorable members of the committee if i
may be so bold i think that today my
bills have gone from at least
controversial to more controversial i
see a
stack of pink cards piling up against me
over there but
thank you again for the record my name
is ellen reed i represent rockingham 17
new market in newfields um so this is
another bill that's been
before you in various versions in the
past or before this committee more
specifically
this bill has two parts
it
requires that an employer
provide a work schedule to their
employees
at least a week in advance
and it requires a rest period of 10
hours between shifts on consecutive days
this only applies to essentially medium
and up sized companies that have either
10 employees or more or have two
locations or more in the state
so i'll take the two pieces separately
scheduling of
of employees work schedules and working
hours
essentially
if you don't provide a schedule in
advance to your employees they can't
schedule their lives
all of us here are here today because we
have scheduled things in our lives
around our duties here but an employee
who doesn't get an advance schedule of
their work
can't schedule their lives oh can you
make it to
this baseball game
i don't know yet i haven't gotten my
schedule yet can you make it to this
birthday party i don't know can you make
it to the state house to testify on a
bill you really care about i don't know
yet i haven't got my schedule yet and
you do have some employers
that may not provide their employees
with the work schedule until literally
the day before they have to work
um i have been in contact with some of
the people who are opposing the bill and
i'm willing to work with them on
language i know that different
industries may look different and i'm
happy to work around that when employees
are not being negatively impacted but my
point is is that people
the the effect that you have when you
don't provide a work schedule to an
employee is that employee is constantly
on call right they don't know
if they're gonna have to work and so
they have to keep their schedule free
for the possibility of work now we have
to pay on call labor and if i can't
schedule my life and live my personal
life and do the things the hobbies the
interests the passions that i have
deepening relationships with people i
care about the things that make life
worth living and i have to hold off on
that because i just don't know whether
or not my employer is going to make me
work
for fear of losing my job
then that's that's not really fair
that's on call time and honestly i it's
not in the bill but it should be paid as
such if you're going to make me hold off
on my private life
so the exemptions here do allow for
employees to
pick up switch shifts agree agree to
work request to work days that are not
in their schedule
but essentially from i think for most
industries and as i said before i'm
willing to
investigate different industries
realities on the ground and
possible exemptions
but for most industries if you as a
manager can schedule one day in advance
then you can schedule seven days in
advance and if people can't make it and
you have to to switch shifts then then
you can do that then but that at least
guarantees the employees the right to
say this wasn't on my original schedule
i've already
promised i'm going to this baseball game
i've already scheduled my doctor's
appointment whatever it is and and say
no
the other piece to this
is the rest period so i have a minimum
rest period of 10 hours between work
shifts on consecutive days
so essentially if you think about a
normal
person's work schedule and they get out
of work and they have eight hours i'm
just gonna go with eight
um they have eight hours between the end
of their work shift in the next work
shift on the next day
they
drive home from work get home
get undressed
make dinner
take care of the kids put them to bed
put themselves to bed
they might have five hours or so of
sleep before they have to wake up do all
of those things get their kids ready for
school make breakfast
shower all of that and then get to work
again
we're literally making people lose sleep
by not ensuring that they have enough
time off in between shifts
so
i did it say consecutive days for a
reason i'm exempting the dreaded split
shift
and being on the labor uh committee i
presume you know a slit shift is but
i'll just share a little bit of my story
i did mention before that i'm a cdl
driver and i drove for public transit
and i had to work split shifts and what
that meant is i had to wake up at 4 am
get to work by 4 45-ish depending on the
day
i do a shift where depending on the day
i'd work from about 4 45 to 11 or 12 in
the middle of the day clock out and then
because i'm a state rep i drive up to
concord like a mad woman usually
changing my clothes in the car
i get up here i do legislative work i
drive like a mad woman back for 4 p.m
work again clock in again at 4 pm clock
out at 9 pm by the time i get home it's
10 and i have to get up at four again
that's a split shift now i don't like it
but some industries need it so that is
exempted
uh i just wanna
let you know that i did exempt that so
it's consecutive days
so again
the aim of the rest period is similar to
the schedule in that we need to give
people time to do the things that make
life worth living otherwise you're just
living to work and i don't think anybody
thinks it's what we should be doing
um so i do want to say and this is a
argument i know you're going to hear
some of the same arguments
against this as you've heard against
other bills previously today
but
one of the arguments is well they don't
have to employees don't have to do this
but they do if they want to keep their
job right like they have to to keep
their job so it is a have to because you
need to pay rent and you need to buy
food
the other thing is and i was very
conservative in that i put the bill in
um as it already existed previously i
don't think i necessarily would have
worded it exactly like this but i wanted
to
kind of work with language that was
familiar
on page two the the top paragraph there
it's an existing rsa that has to do with
sunday it says no employer shall operate
such any such business on sunday
um and then accept yada yada and the the
drafting lawyer as they had done in the
past kind of um tweaked it a little bit
but honestly if it were me i would
strike that entire i don't know that
that's kind of like a blue law right i
don't know why we're treating sunday
special
but um
but anyway i'm just saying
these this is the intent people need
time to work they need some breathing
room i'm happy to work on amendments
that help um
make everybody happy but and with that
i'm willing to take questions
i give you a testimony
i don't see any hands that was one of my
first comments line one employer no
employer shall operate any such
business on sundays unless
so is this only applicable for sundays
that is as i said sir that is existing
rsa and so i just simply didn't strike
existing rsa but that is in our current
law as you can see
where there's strikes in language added
in that paragraph so that means that
it's not my new paragraph
under line six
whoever violates the section shall be
fined fifty dollars um i just thought it
i don't know it should be employer or
manager or owner whoever i you know
you're going to find a
i would take that entire paragraph out
as i've already said it but again i put
it in as it already had existed and
without
i should say minimal changes to current
rsa
on line 14 15 and 16 you talk about
compensation for time and a half uh
before working through rest periods
it was brought to my attention that that
could entice employees who want to get
paid more to
say okay
i'll work three of those hours
your thoughts i
just had part of this conversation with
a couple of the people who will be
testifying against about that very
portion and you did hear you know a bill
earlier today about time and a half
compensation and some of those arguments
will be the same i am fine with removing
that like i said this is a bill as it's
previously existed not as i tailored it
thank you representative any other
questions for the representative
representative prout and representative
after that
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um
what
do you see would prevent an employer if
this were to become law from scheduling
someone
to work say
nine to five seven days a week
and then calling them and canceling the
days they don't actually need them to
basically work around this
because we actually have existing rsas
about the procedures for
canceling previously scheduled work that
this doesn't seem to change
you know that's a good point and again
i put this in as it already existed and
i'm willing to look at amendments to fix
that but i do very very strongly believe
we need to have some protections in
place to allow employees
to know that they're going to have time
off to do the rest of their life so if
we can find a way around to make
everybody happy that is what i will go
for
thank you
thank you mr chairman you
inspired me with your line by line
questions
there was one other i i wondered about
online nine of page two
there's an exception to it all if the
employee requests or consents that seems
really broad
if an employee shows up to work isn't
that not consent which means
does it
apply at all i'm wondering about the
language no i i also did in fact i don't
know if you can see from there but i
literally circled or consents
already knowing that this is a work in
progress knowing that this committee has
had difficulties in the past with this
again this is a starting point and i
want to really work towards the goal of
yes
understanding all the different
industries particulars and what works
for them but also protecting employees
so you know the questions of the
committee thank you for your testimony
thank you so much and don't worry i'm
done for the day
i'm gonna have fun with the next guy
just because
i like him
a man with many titles
honorable mr speaker
mr department head mr commissioner
sean jasper
nice to see you in front of labor
thank you mr chairman it's certainly
nice to be here again twice in one day
members of the committee i am still sean
jasper and still the commissioner of
agriculture
so
i do see this as a a bill again you
could take much of the the testimony
which mr chairman you were introducing
your own bill you didn't hear me earlier
but much of the testimony that i said
that this could be very harmful
to agriculture you know you get into
having to pay people time and a half
much of the same
still applies there are many times when
because of the weather those work shifts
are going to be
extended
so you might be thinking you're going to
work till
five or six but there's a rainstorm
coming in and you're going to work till
dark which goes beyond there and again
there's no additional income
to pay for that it was work you were
planning on doing perhaps the next day
but had to get in early
and give your employees the time off i
think
particularly in this work environment
people have to
to
treat their employees well if you don't
you're going to lose them there are a
lot of
opportunities out there and i and i
question
the timing of putting in
bills such as is this one because the
economy is extraordinarily uh
favorable to to employees at this time
but we have to be
mindful of
the difficulties
that employers face because of the
shortage of workers
and
many people who choose to work in in
fields my daughter's in the restaurant
industry and while at this point she's
on salary even when she was on
hourly
work she was being called in
many many times
um
wasn't able to commit
and
so then her
schedule was adjusted adjusted that's
part of the industry that's part of of
agriculture and i think that um you know
we have to be to be mindful
of that and not put undue burdens
on employers while i appreciate what the
sponsor said
you know
virtually all employee employers today
if an employee asks for time off in
advance
they work around that schedule i do find
that having a full week
have that schedule posted can be
very burdensome because of those type of
things people often
find out about a an event and like oh i
need this off
you know
in five days
and well that's fine if you're doing a
schedule the week before which most
employees
employers small employers do
now what do you do because now you've
got a hole you need to grant that
employee that period of time but
everybody's scheduled and
so
i i think
you know all in all
we need to let the market um
work businesses run as they have been i
don't think there's
um a need at this time and particularly
for government intervention into this
area i'll conclude my testimony
with that and now mr chairman you can
have your fun
any questions for the commissioner
i i have one are there the federal
government puts out
rules regarding
time off between shifts for airline
pilots train engineers
cld drivers on with their with their
logs and stuff is there anything in the
agriculture business that the federal
government has certainly not that i have
heard of or am aware of so
i don't i don't believe so there is
quite a bit of flexibility with with
agriculture due to
the fact that
it is so weather dependent and depend
dependent on
um having to have people do certain jobs
at certain times as i said
this morning you don't have the luxury
of saying oh well we'll milk the cows
you know tomorrow we'll skip tonight
they don't like that too much no
any other questions for the commissioner
see none thank you very much thank you
like to uh call dave duvet from the
bia
gary do you really have to be somewhere
all right here he'll call you next
make him wait
uh thank you mr chair members of the
committee again for the record my name
is dave giuve i'm a senior vice
president with the business and industry
association we have 400 plus members all
across the state
and serve as new hampshire statewide
chamber of commerce we're here in
opposition to this bill and i will admit
up front i understand
the good intentions behind this bill but
there are some questions i'm left with
which is
is this really a problem that needs to
be corrected
and if it is is it reasonable to believe
that every business
has the same issues the same constraints
the same
ability or inability to be flexible
that demands a one-size-fits-all
solution and
my experience is the answer to that is
no there are some specific
issues with the bill i'd like to bring
up
one of which is
it doesn't seem to distinguish between
what we call exempt or non-exempt
employees hourly versus those like
myself that are on salary
i don't my employer doesn't have
a work schedule for me i have job
responsibilities and i'm expected to to
meet those responsibilities and it's not
tied to me being in at the office at
nine and leaving at five so this
bill is uncle it seems to indicate it
applies to everybody
so does that mean employers who have
salaried individuals are now going to
have to have
work schedules for those individuals
that are
conspicuously
noticed in the workplace
and speaking about conspicuous notice
the bill is a little unclear on
what has to be conspicuous in the notice
is this referring to just general work
schedules of the organization
or is it referring to specific
individuals because there are many
companies manufacturing companies
financial services companies
they may have a thousand employees or
more
and so is the bill requiring the
employer to have some type of
huge wall chart whichever with
everyone's individual schedules noted
not just in english but in a second
language
that may be used within the workplace so
it just seems
at very many levels to be impractical
and again i get back to is this really
necessary
employers right now are under a lot of
constraints which i mentioned in
previous testimony earlier today
and we are asking for
flexibility every business is different
and we need to trust uh the managers and
owners of those businesses that they
will conduct uh themselves you know in a
way that is good for the employees and
the business no employer wants to have
an employee who's falling asleep on the
job because they've had insufficient
time between their previous
work
on the other hand some employees or some
employers may want to have the
flexibility to ask someone to work
overtime in a crunch time which it seems
like this bill would prohibit so mr
chair that concludes my testimony i'd be
happy to try and answer any questions
thank you mr javier any questions
representative hattiton
thank you mr chairman
um
mr gervais one thing i didn't hear in
your testimony was
uh reference to page two line ten
um or line seven through what looks like
thirteen uh where we're talking about
uh mandatory rest periods uh in between
shifts can i get uh your opinion or
position on that specific segment
um
when you say page two are you referring
to page one of the bill
it's labeled as page two okay yeah and
um
yeah it looks like section yeah it's
section two line uh seven through 13.
well i guess i have a couple of comments
one is
this doesn't the the whole question
about consent has already been brought
up and is a little vague
uh the second thing
is and i recognize that the sponsor says
this was not something she
intentionally had in there but the
compentate compensation at one and a
half times is something we addressed
earlier today that is something that
that i don't think is
necessary or something the bia could
support
and i would say
just in general
trying to
come up with a with a
assuming you first of all believe that
there's a problem that needs to be
corrected coming up with a
one-size-fits-all
um solution for every business generally
will create more problems than than
you're trying to solve
follow up uh with permission from the
chair can i provide context with the
kind of question that i'm trying to ask
thank you mr chairman
um in in researching this bill um i
found some information from the national
highway traffic and safety
administration
in 2019 there were about 700 vehicle
fatalities associated with drowsy
driving
if you have employers in the state of
new hampshire where it's a
depending on where you live longer
commute
and you don't have
that kind of rest period in between it
raises the elevation for a potential
fatality
my question is
is there will from
either yourself or the via
um to do something uh with this
legislation regarding
um having a mandatory rest period in
between as an end to reducing vehicle
fatalities
well i appreciate the question and you
and i don't know each other well but
some people here know that for many many
years i worked for
aaa the auto club specifically in their
traffic safety department and worked on
a lot of legislation relating to that
especially to drunk driving and seat
belt usage and so on
i don't recall ever
working on
legislation requiring mandatory break
time to reduce instances of fatigue but
i can tell you from my personal
experience that i do appreciate
that there is are risks inherent with
fatigued driving which is
why to the chair's question earlier
there are federal regulations for
commercial truck drivers in terms of the
amount of time they can spend on the
road and the amount of break times that
they need to have
between the times that they're driving
so it's recognized as an issue i
maintain that most employers
are reasonable and don't want to put
their employees at any um
unnecessary risk but i will also say
there are
probably many instances where an
employee
might reach out to an employee and say
so and so didn't come up come into work
today i just found out is there any way
you can come in
earlier and it not be
outside of that 10 hour minimum and
for most reasonable the employer
employers the employee can say i can't i
can't keep my eyes open right now i
don't think i can drive safely
so
my preference is always to let this work
out between the employee and the
employer i mentioned
earlier today that this is not
a
we're not living through a time where
employers can
enact draconian policies without a
negative ramification of employees
leaving because it's too easy to find
employment somewhere else
follow-up
thank you mr chairman um you did and
the regulations regarding uh pilots and
truck drivers and train
drivers were brought up
would you believe there's a similar
mechanical risk to operating a truck
with that kind of sleep deprivation to
driving a car for a commute i i
as i mentioned i have a background in
traffic safety issues i would readily
admit that
thank you any additional questions
xenon thank you thank you mr chair
glad to call
gary abbott
from the associated general contractors
uh amy charbonneau
i do have a meeting actually amy is
going to the same meeting so be great if
we
testify together
so gary abbott from the associate
general contractors amy charbonneau
continental paving
here i reckon
thank you very much chairman uh again
for the record my name's gary abbott the
executive vice president of the
associated general contractors of new
hampshire
come to date in
opposition to house bill
and
as you heard earlier this morning i
represent the commercial and
construction industry both highway and
building
this bill
really doesn't fit the construction
industry
clearly we are scheduling sometimes
daily every other day
the seven day just does not work for us
uh we did talk to i did talk to the
sponsor we actually both talked to the
sponsor before the hearing
and uh
this just would be so problematic for us
to
all entertain now i know the sponsor
talked about maybe making an exemption
uh but that i think
this has ramifications on the second
part as well with the uh
10 hour and the rest period that we
talked about earlier this morning
i have with me amy charbonneau from
continental paving
definitely involved in scheduling within
her company and i don't know if you want
to add some things here um
continental paving we do paving
construction heavy highway all
throughout the state we have about 350
employees
99 of them are from new hampshire
when our employees come into the
construction industry they they know
what industry they're in
but we also know how tough the schedule
is for them so as a family run business
we do a lot to do all the things that
the sponsor mentioned
but not under a blanket rule that it's
totally different than the way we do it
so we understand it's a lot of long
hours and a disruptive schedule some
days but what we do is we always try and
give weekends off we do a lot of things
like an early friday or we do ways to
make up for the things that our industry
makes us do on a daily basis we only
have so many months a year to get our
life done
and i guess the important part that a
lot of people don't realize or the
sponsor is that we don't have a door
that locks and unlocks you know opens in
the morning and closes at night we can
have a machine that breaks down and our
guys are two hours away and they have to
make it back and or we you know you have
10 trucks on the road full of asphalt
and the paver breaks you still have to
fix that paver and you still have to put
all that asphalt down because
realistically the state's paying for it
so i got to get those guys to finish
their job they have to come back we
start them late in the morning if we
have to we do make all those on the
moment adjustments but it's very hard to
say that what's going to happen seven
days prior to that and to schedule that
so our
industry knows what they're doing
for work and i think a lot of our
businesses new hampshire's full of
family businesses in this industry and
we do work with our employees we love
our employees so there's that we do it
instead of a law doing it and i would
just ask that it stays that way
thank you yeah and i'd just like to add
amy's from the highway side but the
building side almost does the same thing
with a building project
these projects you know you don't know
how long a subcontractor when he's going
to finish before the next subcontractor
could get on the job scheduling is not
done that far out so when anybody's
trying to do this
this bill just does i mean as soon as
you bring it up to my legislative
committee or my board of directors
immediately
we we just couldn't do this and so
that's why we're here in opposition to
it
um
i know we've talked about this before
and i would leave that with the
committee and answer any questions the
committee may have thank you very
much any questions for the presenters
i have one um
you folks can't pay when it rains all
right correct you had a tough time this
year what were you what did you do
when we had rain every other day or two
or three days in a row when you still
had to get the work done how are you
able to deal with that so there's a lot
of times i mean we as a company i can
only speak for ourselves but
when you have two or three days in a row
a lot of times we end up paying guys for
eight hours they call in the morning and
they don't come in we're very generous
to our employees because we want them to
keep working for us
um other days so then say it rains
monday tuesday on wednesday you decide
it's going to be 80 degrees and sunny on
saturday i gotta pave on saturday but it
my employees want to pave on saturday
because i may have paid them for one or
two days but i can't pay them for all
three so they want to work saturday
because they didn't they want they want
their overtime they live for their
overtime so that their wives can stay
home i mean there's a lot of benefits to
what we do in the overtime it the rain
the weather frost in the fall i mean so
we may not start till nine o'clock but
you don't know the day before tomorrow's
gonna be super cold hey you i can't have
you come in till nine o'clock but you're
gonna work a little later the sun's
coming out and it's gonna be great
so it's just it's always fluid and but
for the most part they work from six in
the morning to four or five o'clock at
night
but it's not i can't keep it as
structured as the paper wants me to so
they generally know when they're working
and then there's a couple adjustments
here and there that we try and make to
the best of everybody's ability but we
as like a family want them to have
family time we we strive for that
because if a happy employee makes great
work so i just believe that the industry
let us handle it on our own it's more
versus legislation and paperwork and
office people
thank you thank you any additional
questions for the presenters
sitting on thank you very much
i have though karnak has the last card
in his hand
i like to call mr bruce berkey
he hasn't signed up but we'll ask him
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee again bruce burkey with
sheen vinnie capital group and
again representing several of our
clients who are opposed to
house bill 1094
the new hampshire lodging and restaurant
association ski new hampshire white
mountain attractions the national
federation of independent business
all of them are opposed to this because
of the constraints that you've just
heard about from
mr abbott and ms charbonneau they gave
very good testimony and i won't try to
go above and beyond that but it is clear
that
weather plays a huge
role in the tourism community
it does with the paving community and it
does with other businesses
and so it really the the businesses and
their and their administrative staff
they need the flexibility
to be able to provide the opportunities
for people to work here in new hampshire
and not to be
put in a straitjacket by a bill like
this with that i'll conclude my
testimony mr chair
happy to try and address any questions
thank you
any questions for mr
burkey see none thank you very much
thank you oh i'm sorry
sorry yeah sorry mr chairman thank you
wonderful um
yes i um
uh i i note that you
ended your testimony by talking about
the opportunity that would be made
available to
workers and
of course this
this bill
excludes circumstances where
an employee would request
or consent once that gets clarified
uh so i mean clearly the opportunity
could exist
um so so
my question is twofold
do you not see this bill as
um
already allowing for an opportunity for
workers to
gain the additional uh hours that
they're interested in and secondly we've
had testimony uh such as from the
gentleman from the bia and others
about
um
trusting
business and and the business to to deal
with workers as they need to do
would you agree that
businesses could trust workers to
respond to the needs that the companies
have
in a manner
that if we're trusting
that it could work both ways
thank you for the question
representative that that you know there
are two separate distinct sections of
the spill
and and
certainly speaking to the first section
about having the seven day schedule in
advance that is the straight jacket
the second section what you're talking
about with respect to consent
um there's there's some good there but
there's also some bad there and and the
bad being the time and a half pay rate
that would ensue and and that would uh
you know begin to put uh constraints on
on businesses because you know maybe
they don't offer that shift so the
person doesn't get the extra shift um
maybe
they they don't say open as late
um you know that the next hire
doesn't get hired because they're paying
extra so i i don't think that a state
mandate
along the lines of what this bill would
put forth is uh appropriate for the
business community
all right thank you i don't see any
other questions
thank you very much thank you does the
committee need to hear from commissioner
ogden
uh debbie grisham would you mind taking
the witness stand don't
representative abalone you're
recognized for a question thank you mr
chairman thank you deputy commissioner
um
section one page i'm sorry
page two section one
line four the employees shall promptly
file a copy of such schedule and every
change therein with the labor
commissioner
would that
require
additional staff for your
unit
for the record uh rudy ogden deputy
commissioner partner of labor in terms
of just accepting them uh no i don't
think that we would need additional
staff in terms of accepting them
presumably we'd be able to receive them
electronically or in some other format
and process them
i don't know that we would need
additional folks to accept those
thank you um do you know how many
employers would be filing schedules if
this happens to pass
i don't know i i don't have that i could
try and find a confirmation of what the
number might be
yes and the uh fine
would that be
administered by your
staffing
people
your investigators would be going out
and making sure that everybody's filed
their
schedule with any relative change given
the testimony we've heard that some of
them are daily changes
that would
be in violation
if there was going to be
someone looking at whether there was a
violation that would be our staff
correct
then you would follow up yes and you
would enforce the 15 time
if it's in the law we would enforce it
yeah thank you
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
mr ogden for coming up
since we have you here
i wanted to ask about the the sponsor
talked about this kind of oddity of the
sunday law it
provides for a day of rest but is very
specific if that day of rest isn't
sunday
requiring that basically the employer
get the permission of the commissioner
for sunday work with some
explicit exceptions i was wondering if
and i you've probably done it before for
me but if you can
characterize how frequent is this done
that the commissioner has had to grant
permission for an employer to have
sunday employment
i'm only aware of a few instances we
most recently had a request and again we
didn't have it specific to sunday it was
the day of rest because what it talks
about is not having folks work on a
sunday unless unless in the perspective
the next six days there's going to be a
day of rest i'm aware we did have a
request for that over the holidays it
was a supply chain company
and they in order to service or
prepare fulfillment they did say okay
we're going to have no day of rest for
some period of time the workers are all
amenable to it but it is
infrequent all right thank you if i
follow up follow up uh just to clarify
um
it sounds like the department's
interpretation of this law is if
an employer
is providing a day of rest that is not
sunday
they don't have any special hoops
let's say restaurants often offer monday
off so they can work the weekend
they don't have to go through the
department to say we're moving our day
of rest until monday and we like the
commission correct it would be looking
for a day of rest
thank you very much
thank you mr chairman thank you rudy uh
deputy commissioner ogden um
the no employer with
page two line seven no employer with ten
or more employees in the state
would you would you
assume that that would be full-time
employees or part-time employees or
part-time employees that equal 10
full-time positions
based on the way it's written we would
assume any and all because in our laws
typically we do not have a distinction
between full-time part-time it's just a
matter of number of employees so again
for purposes of the department's
administration of this bill
we would look at 10 or more employees
whether they be part-time or full-time
thank you thank you mr chairman
president
thank you mr chairman
and thank you
uh deputy commissioner for taking my
question um the the sponsor of the bill
alluded to that workers need protection
and and to that i would ask do you get
complaints in your department about work
scheduling and lack of rest
i
know but i would point out that perhaps
we're not getting those complaints
because there is not a protection in
place so i just want to be very clear on
that we do not get calls on this
but in part i believe that might be
because there is not an existing
protection or provision okay thank you
question
okay seeing no other hands
i have no more thank you very much uh
commissioner i have no other pink cards
is there anyone else who would like to
speak
seeing none i'm closing the hearing on
house bill
1094 and we have 15 minutes for the next
hearing
i'm going to eat my soup
do the members of the republican members
of committee understand that there will
be a caucus after session
okay
um
and that was it was completely
inadequate but i ended up having several
the other side of the aisle who
represented sea coast things
everybody knows
which actually
in some cases
there's a solution
i think we'll know because he was
looking at that
again
so then she had to sail home
it's been a while
okay so we keep my mother happy
gonna be on time
uh folks i have been remiss should have
done this
um these are the sign up sheets and
normally what we do is we'll read them
you know
uh
we did we kind of had a hard time doing
that on online
last session
last year
we had so many people online it was very
difficult
so
they're all here for viewing um
two or three people signed up when they
usually sign up they all so in this case
it's almost every single person here who
signed up also testified
for the most part um so if anyone would
like to see these but from now on i will
um i will ask the
clerk to to get me these or whatever or
our assistant so we can read them
representative sullivan
i i know we have the opportunity to sign
on to um bills either in opposition or
support online are you getting those
lists
as well
uh representative i think that just
started two days ago
is it i thought they just reimplemented
that
okay i have not been getting them
i go ahead please
i guess if if we're not getting copies
of it and being informed of it i'm not
sure what the point is i mean i've i've
been signing in on bills that i think
are important
but if no one's ever seeing the fact
that i signed in on it i don't know what
i'm why i'm doing it
um
that would be helpful thank you
i'll give you my opinion a second but i
have a couple questions avalani cahill
thank you mr chairman um is the
sheets added to the red folder at the
end of
the day
my understanding was that you had to
sign in on a bill like at a certain time
in the morning if the bill was being
heard
but as far as the report i think it
would be useful at least
for our executive sessions to have not
every name read but perhaps the number
of people who are opposed or
or uh in favor of and i think the the
idea was to have the emails forwarded to
the committee
prior to the executive session
thank you what i am going to do is uh
specifically i'm going to ask heather
when she gets them or whoever to make
sure it gets sent out to that generic
the house labor committee site so you
all you will all have them
specifically
lino i will find out
just to make sure
those go in the permanent
red file
um
and
regarding prior to executive session
me reading them out um mike i would
rather
at the end of the hearing i
read
the
blue sheets that are in here
um
and then be presented to everybody else
or we can see them versus me reading
them off
is that unacceptable to everybody
well that that's what i meant those ones
online will be sent we will request
heather send them to all of us again at
the end of the evening probably the next
day after people have the opportunity
especially if they
you know are listening and they want to
make a comment or sign in before in
favor or against after hearing that
we'll give them until the end of the day
all right
all right let me find out
okay sorry uh representative abramson um
for the
clerical things here to deal with i
would uh open
hearing on house bill
1231 fn relative to failure to make
payment of compensation and represent
and call on
the sponsor representative max abramson
welcome representative
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee my name is representative max
abramson
um and i'm uh representing hampton
hampton falls and seabrook and i'm here
introducing house bill 1231 uh which
deals with uh
workman's comp payments that are that
are paid late
i became aware
uh i work in the
in the construction trades
and i became aware
talking with other workers that new
hampshire has
although we're great as a a great place
to set up a business and we're one of
the lowest tax states in the country and
one of the lowest prime states in the
country a lot of great thing things
about new hampshire
one of the weak points has been
that we've developed a reputation for
not having the most not having the most
responsive workman's comp system and so
we have
a lot of blue-collar workers who
in the new england market who will not
work in new hampshire and the reason is
that they've had a bad experience
with
being injured on the job through no
fault of their own and they
they get disqualified and they have to
hire an attorney and
fight through the system to try to get
compensation the the problem with that
is
is while you're waiting
usually three to six months to actually
get comp uh compensation
um
you as the worker who have been injured
through no fault of your own
you as the worker are facing these
really high interest and penalty
rates you're not getting
medical treatment
if you are you're having to pay for the
doctor's visits and x-rays and tests on
your own
a lot of workers have faced
eviction repossession repossession of
vehicles uh 29 interest rates on their
credit cards that they have to pay while
they're waiting and waiting and waiting
to get
reimbursements they faced foreclosure
bankruptcy
medical bills or medical tests that
don't get performed
so they can't get fully diagnosed until
they actually go in for an mri mri could
be 800 or a thousand dollars just to
look at a small
section of injured tissue
delayed retraining longer recovery time
or inadequate care
something that might be resolved in you
know six or eight months ends up taking
over two years
because you
if you don't happen to have the cash on
hand and you don't have your credit
cards already maxed out
um you can't get the medical care and so
you can't get the the
injury taken care of so with the intent
of the bill
uh was and i spoke with the department
of of uh
labor just a few minutes ago and they
had a number of questions on the on the
actual methodology but
the the compromise
right now on workman's comp is that we
let the company take a discount they pay
only 60 percent of your base pay and
none of your overtime
right now if they start paying right
away and then they and
covering your your medical costs and
your doctor's visits and x-rays
the formula that i proposed
was that if a company is more than 60
days late if they're dragging their feet
or they're simply refusing to pay or
they're forcing you to to go through the
department of labor
was to have them just pay 100 of your
base wages for anything that's more than
60 days behind
but there are other dif there are other
formulas there are different ways to do
it right now what's happening is
um the department of labor in a
particularly abusive case they can find
the company up to twenty five hundred
dollars
um and there's also uh
uh interest that the company has to pay
for paying late but that rate of
interest is is
uh far far lower it's a very small
fraction of the losses faced by the
workers themselves
so if if the company's going to dispute
it if the company is going to fight it
or the company's just
you know
dragging their feet or they're being
non-responsive
or could be errors within uh areas of
communication um
among the
the two or three companies that are that
are processing that case
um
it may be the company's fault it may be
the adjuster's fault it may be someone
just went on vacation and or paperwork
was lost but it's not the fault
it's not the fault of the worker
themselves and yet the worker is the one
having to pay
you know the 29 interest rate on their
credit card the workers the one facing
vehicle repossession the worker is the
one having to pay for all the costs
of some paperwork errors on the part of
the company
so we
i'm not advocating for
creating a hostile anti-business
environment what i'm advocating for is
having a sufficient penalty maybe
even rewriting the bill just to increase
the interest rate
like anything else to force the company
for
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for testifying and taking
our questions today
um could you
on page one section lines 22 through 28.
can you talk me through how you arrived
at this
yes i i just used the same formula
that's already
present where
uh if a if the adjuster pays on time
that they pay 60 percent of the base
wages and i simply said
using the exact same formula
um
you know minimum weight minimum
of 30 percent of the state's average
weekly wage or
no more than 250 percent of the state's
average weekly wage that's the formula
that's already used in statute
um instead of 60 anything that's more
than 60 days late they would just pay
on the presumption that the worker is
actually having to
uh fight the case
in other words you no longer give them
the 40 discount for paying on time
because they're not paying on time
thank you
representative cahill followed by
sullivan
representative sullivan followed by mr
cahill representative cahill
thank you representative cahill those
very gracious of you
thank you for taking my question um
looking at the same paragraph that
representative avalani was referring to
it says for payments made to an employee
more than 60 days after the injury is
first reported
so um this would include
the time period where um
a
employee is reported but has not yet
been approved for workers comp is that
correct
right it's it's meant to
it's meant to get the adjuster
to move a little bit quicker
not uh
if if you're having to wait 60 days
after an injury that's that's two months
without any pay there are a lot of
things that go into collections within
60 days follow-up
follow-up
if the
claim is denied
and the employee um
appeals the denial
and eventually is approved
all of that time would um
also be contributed to the 60 days is
that correct
um that would all
fall under the higher 100 rate and then
anything paid
um
once a judgment or ruling is made
against the company and they start
paying on time they would pay at the
lower 60 percent rate
so in other words it's what what this is
intended to
hit the company with is
uh if you report an injury today
and and two months goes by and you now
realize you've got to take this to the
department of labor
you've got to hire an attorney that's
he's going to take 20 percent of your
your
total so that's going to take you down
from 100
all the way down to 80
and then you're you're still
accumulating debt and you're still
accumulating interest in penalties
so it's meant to be anything that's more
than 60 days
in arrears
representative cahill
thank you mr chair and thank you
representative for taking my question i
i wanted to point out that i know you
mentioned that
the employee is injured through no fault
of his own workers comp is basically a
no-fault
institution that we have to protect the
employer from litigation
so it really is the dispute may be that
the did the injury occur at work or was
it when uh
mountain biking on the weekend
or or there may be some other
other issues i i don't know i'd be
curious to hear from course
deputy ogden and our own chair who's
very familiar with workers comp if there
really is such a problem
in new hampshire i think we've talked
about this issue before with trying to
incentivize prompt payment
and it may be that you know the raising
the interest rate could be better but
can you tell me i know you've also
mentioned that new hampshire has a lot
of going for it except for the very low
taxes do you own the home
yes i do
thank
you okay
and uh i'm aware that the property taxes
are going way up on the seacoast
right now but it's still an overall low
tax burden
without a medival
yes i'm i'm so uh thank you mr chairman
thank you uh representative abramson for
testifying i'm afraid i didn't hear i
don't think i correctly heard your
response to uh representative sullivan's
question
is it your testimony that the intention
of the bill is
if a
a claim is
submitted
and
is
the subject of some dispute
and then ultimately it's agreed or
determined that it should be paid
is is it the at the 100 percent or at a
60 percent post some point in time
yeah uh
so that's that's a good question it's
it's the the part of the claim that's
denied and not paid and is just dragged
out
something that's a 60-day delay usually
goes on for a lot longer than it's
usually you know several months before
you actually get payment
but once the company starts making the
payment if they're making payments on
time after that six months from now that
that amount should be paid at 60 percent
but
if it's just like any other payment if
you're making your your car payment or
or your credit card payment or payment
on medical bills or what have you if
you're late
the amount that you're late is what what
gets charged the interest in penalties
yes thank you um yes thanks for
clarifying that um and i assume of
course that
i should read this to discuss
payments as
those
that the carrier
are determined to be obligated to pay or
agree to pay
i mean this doesn't create some kind of
no fault no fault where
by virtue of the passage of time
payments become due is that a correct
statement correct okay uh my my intent
was that this wouldn't cost employers
anything
it would just
you would know that your carrier would
start you know getting a little bit more
responsive thank you
representative cahill
uh i think i'm going to beat mr avilani
to this um
what would there be a cost to this that
might be passed on to the
people that insured businesses if the
carriers have to pay more wouldn't they
likely wouldn't this transfer to higher
rates for everyone who pays workers comp
uh i don't think so and the the reason
is right now um in business to business
payments if there's a if there's a
penalty structure built in businesses
just pay on time
the unlikely event
would be that a company has to borrow
money to pay six months sooner you know
in order to pay on time and the the
interest rate that businesses are paying
if they're paying six months sooner the
interest rate on on six months is not
um
a very large amount of money might my
expectation is my experience has been
that with the complaints that i've
gotten from people is just that the the
carrier is
taking a long time to just process
paperwork that they're sitting on a case
for a long period of time for whatever
reason that they would just move quicker
if there were a penalty
a higher interest rate if for for kind
of dilly-dallying that they would they
would move a little bit quicker i don't
think it'd be an increase in cost
thank you representative sullivan
when i saw this thank you for taking my
question thank you mr chairman
um
when i saw this bill it reminded me of
a bill that we saw a few years ago
um from a
representative from lancaster i believe
and
it was based on his own personal
experience and i think
when i saw a late payment
it brought me back back to his issue and
i believe his issue was
dealing with
insurance companies that were just
really lousy at getting their payments
out so he was dealing with a late
payment
once it was approved and it just wasn't
getting his money
um
if
it seems that this bill would apply to
that but only if a company was actually
delaying payments by up to 60 days is
that right
if the payment were made within 60 days
there wouldn't be any penalty under this
bill
and and it is
what i have seen is that some
some insurance companies they should not
be in the insurance business
they might be in the insurance business
because they're actually an investment
firm and they found that they can bring
in some revenue
from uh insurance
the benefit of insurance is that
something unexpected happens with a car
collision or life insurance or claim or
something
of that sort the insurance company is
supposed to pay right away
and it might be very large unexpected
cost something that's completely random
for someone to be in the insurance
business they really need to pay out
claims quickly process them quickly and
pay them quickly and some companies are
not doing that
as i recollected it it was an issue such
as that but
these companies just weren't weren't
accustomed to actually doing something
similar to payroll
you know and
we're continually
um
slipping up with getting the payments
out on time
in
in memory of the uh representative from
lancaster it would be nice if we could
address that as well but that's uh
probably another bill
absolutely i would agree with that
any further questions for the
representative abramson
cena thank you very much for your
testimony
i need to call
deputy commissioner rudy ogden from the
department of labor
thank you chairman of rudy ogden deputy
commissioner department of labor as
representative abramson mentioned we
just did speak briefly the department
relative to this bill and not to rehash
old things that have uh come up in in
your folks questions but we did have
some technical questions namely related
to this issue as presently
drafted for payments made to an employee
more than 60 days after the injury is
first reported
i do think that it's worth figuring out
where exactly you want to tether that to
you could very well have an injury
reported
and not have an order for payment or
anything
uh indicating that the carrier or the
employer is responsible for anything
until well after 60 days have passed and
that is not always a matter of people
dragging their feet or not doing what
they're supposed to be doing it could be
that you have an injury
you report that injury you don't end up
getting treatment until 90 days later
you don't have a medical bill you don't
have any missed time so i just want to
point out that in terms of if we're
talking about late payments late
payments is somewhat different than just
saying 60 days after an injury is first
reported
the other thing we had as a question for
purposes of technical consideration
is where it says if an employee's
average weekly wage is more than 30 of
the state's average weekly wage weekly
compensation shall be and then it goes
on we would just want to be clear that
you know is this intended to not provide
this premium payment or enhanced payment
to those individuals making less than 30
of the average weekly wage so again one
way of structuring this to the extent
you're
looking to do this type of
notion would be to just say everybody is
going to get this enhanced
payment upon late late pay
the only other thing i would point out
just in terms of generalized information
i'm not aware of like this general
discontent of you know workers all over
not liking new hampshire other than
we do oftentimes hear about folks don't
like the fact that our indemnity rate is
60 of their average weekly wage i
understand there's a lot of there's
policy to that i understand there was a
compromise made in terms of why it's not
but i just point out that that is
something we hear as a generalized
complaint about workers comp
in new hampshire the other thing that we
hear about in terms of complaints in
this context is as
under existing law the department is
entitled if you have a carrier that is
flagrantly late representative
sullivan brought up this notion we have
dealt with carriers before who have had
a history or bad practice or pattern
they can be fined but that fine goes to
the department and there have been
complaints from individual or affected
workers saying
i'm the worker the payments were late to
me yes you find them and maybe that's a
deterrent going forward but the fine
doesn't you you recovering that fine
doesn't help me for my lap my uh
inconveniences or added costs or
expenses that i've incurred so that
again i just point that out not out of
any sense of defensiveness but just two
instances in which the department has
heard of concerns in this area the only
other thing i would point out because
you folks often ask
are we aware of yes there are issues
where carriers pay late uh we do have
incentives where the check is supposed
to be there on a friday and the person
doesn't get it to a monday when we are
made aware of those instances we go
after you know the carrier it's not
always a fine we're not issuing a fine
every single time
but we are trying to work to get those
corrected but that does come up i do
think direct deposit has cured or
alleviated some of these concerns
not everyone though elects to do direct
deposit additionally when folks do
direct deposit sometimes there's a lag
in setting that up where it you know
they set up the direct deposit and then
it takes some time to set in so i'm
happy to answer any questions but just
wanted to provide that additional
context and as representative abramson
said um we did have some technical
questions if the parties want to move
forward with this we're willing to and
happy to try and help in any way in
terms of the language
deputy commissioner could you explain to
the committee
what the
procedure is
now in a scenario where an
injured employee
is unhappy
with the
handling of a workers compensation claim
so most often times if they're unhappy
with something if they have on their own
they would call
and uh
unhappy in the sense of how the claim
has been handled um if they're not
getting their check if they're not
hearing back from the adjuster this is
the beginning of the claim
uh they're not the employer hasn't
provided the information on payroll all
usually the first two weeks
that seems to be the issue
getting these things started so
i know what the procedure is in place
but i'd like you to tell everyone
when that person contacts us what
contacts us whether it is in writing or
over the phone they're put in touch with
a couple of different people in our
office who then would go and say okay
what do we have on file procedurally or
process wise where is this case or claim
at and then what that person does is
they then go reach out to if there is a
carrier assume there is a carrier
they're reaching out to the carrier and
saying okay where are we at on this
and they're trying to you know push and
what we're ultimately trying to do
is we do understand this idea of feet
dragging needing bills to get paid if
there's a dispute if the parties are
actually into a ripened dispute if
someone asks for a hearing by law
they're supposed to get a hearing within
six weeks now certainly the parties will
say oh i want to continue this or we're
willing to continue it we'd be looking
for both sides willing to continue it
but i just want to what our efforts are
trying to do is to your point if
someone's unsatisfied or they think
something's not happening we try and
talk to the parties get the parties to
make and get everything in the file what
needs to happen then we try and say is
there a dispute does someone want to ask
for a hearing or is this something that
can be worked out or taken care of
if it can't be worked out and taken care
of then it's like okay somebody asked
for a hearing and then we're trying to
push it okay within sex six weeks let's
get a hearing scheduled so folks can
dispute that issue
thank you a few
years ago you had a workers comp
carrier that was notorious
my word not yours
for late payments
i know the department addressed that but
what is the
fine uh
mechanism that you have the ability to
bring forth upon an insurance carrier
for
late payments
so 408 payment as was mentioned by the
sponsor we could find up to 2500 dollars
for that in incident so
uh if they're late every week you know
you could find them per incident saying
you know you've been late on that
payment i will say in addition to fining
typically what we try and do
is ask for a meeting with the carrier
and they've been in the situation where
the carrier will send certain of their
adjusters in or certain of their
manager's ways is it just people being
relaxed
those that are late some are better than
others but we've usually been able to
work through them and at least get them
when we're aware of an issue on some
type of track going forward
thank you representative cahill
thank you mr chairman and thank you
deputy commissioner uh how do we define
late
as far as the payments when they're due
or the
speed of the
claim being evaluated and just and
determined what are there some
rules there yeah so in the most basic
sense if there's an order for payment
there will be an order for payment in
which it'll say pay within x if it's an
indemnity payment similar to almost a
payroll it's supposed to be set up with
okay this payment is going to happen
you know and it'll be on friday and then
every you know there is a set schedule
and the carrier is aware of that
schedule either through an order or
through an arrangement between the you
know okay indemnity payments are going
to start they'll kick in and they should
be sequential after that follow up
so how long generally between the injury
and the payment start
is there a standard for that or that's a
really good question i think i'd want to
get additional information for that
because again some of these cases
there's no dispute at all they're
accepted they start moving and payment
could happen right away to the sponsor's
point there are certainly incidents in
which
you know the employees waiting to see is
the claim going to be accepted but
there's only 21 days to accept or deny
but sometimes what happens
is if there's an initial denial
oh we denied it because we need more
information please employees supply more
information and then sometimes the
employee takes some time to gather it
because to the sponsors point if they
don't have an attorney and not everyone
should need an attorney but if they
don't have an attorney sometimes it
takes the employee some time to gather
that information put together what they
think is
what's needed and get there so there can
be delays so i have a hard time
apologies answering what would be an
average case i can certainly ask folks
in the department i think i could get a
more credible answer than i can convey
right now one more follow-up follow-up
uh might there be
delays in getting information from the
medical community that's treating the
patient
yes i would say that uh there are many
instances in which uh the parties are
waiting for
the the medical record you know that
okay did the person see a treating
physician
has that made it where it needs to be do
they have sufficient medicals to make a
determination or move
thank you very much
any other questions for the question
i have a few additional
approximately
uh
ballpark it no one's gonna hold you to
it
approximately how many complaints do you
think a month you receive for late
payments
for late payments um
and i'm not talking about the ones that
friday to monday that you know or what
have you although i know that's still an
issue that you're trying to resolve and
the um direct deposit has helped that
but i'm talking about someone that's a
week late two weeks late
things like that with
significant
um issues with the carrier
a handful of times a month and when i
say a handful i'm probably saying a
10 or less
i would say on average that's the amount
now that might be happening a lot more
than that but i'm saying incidents of
people actually calling in and saying
uh payments late needs i need help i
would say
10 or a lot 10 or less a month one final
question
which you may not want to answer
do you feel the fine is appropriate or
should it be adjusted
i would say the fines appropriate in the
sense of if we
wanted to issue a 2500 penalty for every
late incident i actually think that you
would see deterrence
in there and it's probably something i
don't want to say out loud but i do
understand this idea of
folks being frustrated that they're not
getting the money so
again a penalty from us i see as a
deterrent
but the fact that that penalty in no way
uh is then attributed or provided to the
uh
the injured claimant i see as is
somewhat problematic but again that's a
policy decision
thank you
i have to keep looking representative
mandeville because i'm not used to
saying your name so i want to make sure
i have it right that's why every time
you put your finger up i'm looking to
make sure i'm saying it right represent
medical you're recognized thank you mr
chairman uh and thank you uh deputy
ogden um
but
particular to this this proposed bill
in light of your testimony about
uh the
date the injury is first reported
would
you either feel more comfortable if the
time that the trigger
was
some period of time say 45 days
following
a
timely determination
or
some other means of
establishing a proper time frame that
takes into account
what the carrier has to do to
deal with or adjust the claim
representative thank you i think that's
a great question to be clear
when we initially the department saw
this bill we were considering it more
akin to representative sullivan's point
as a late payment bill
when i thought it was a late payment
bill i would say certainly we'd feel it
more clear and comfortable if it was
saying payment after a date where
there's an order due or something like
that to be fair to the sponsor if the
sponsor's point is to say no i want to
accelerate the entire system
this would accelerate the entire system
but i do think you're then running into
those issues where
payment was never ordered the carrier
never knew there was going to be payment
ordered and now it's past 60 days so
again i think that's something has to be
looked at
follow mr chairman
um
that
thank you
that's why i said timely determination
uh because it could be a denial or an
approval um and if it were
an approval then you're dealing with
representative sullivan's situation if
it's a denial
then you're at a point in time where
it either was or was not denied properly
and the chips fall where they do but
would
would that deal with both
concerns while also allowing the carrier
the opportunity to adjust it properly
i i think it could i i think that some
adjustment in that vein could do do that
thank you
thank you mr chairman thank you deputy
commissioner um
so when you assess a penalty
um of up to 2 500
are you able to also make a
determination of restitution to
the
employee
if they were had a late payment or
considerably payments or they've had or
it's gone beyond any reasonable amount
of time
can the department of labor order that
they pay
back this and plus interest plus
fees or something like that do you guys
have the ability to do that no so
presently what there is is the ability
for a penalty paid to the department and
there is the opportunity for interest on
a payment to the claimant so that that
could happen interest on a late payment
uh but you would have no extraordinary
payment or restitution to the claimant
thank you
yeah
is there uh is there a statutory uh
interest rate is it one percent a month
is it is there anything in statute it
tracks to the same rate and if you look
actually on the text here of the
proposed bill it does track we're using
the same rate as judgments as under uh
336-1 so it's the statutory or the court
prescribed rate of judgment on awards
thank you any further questions
the deputy commissioner
um xenon thank you very much
we have one last pink card
and that is
george russos
from oren reno
representing a bunch of letters
new hampshire a-d-i-c and a-p-c-i-a
x-y-z pdq
it's just too long to write it all out
mr chairman so
but i will uh i haven't appeared before
the
committee a long time so
it's a pleasure to be here and i will
take the opportunity at least this once
to mention who who um who i am here
representing so
first of all my name is george russos
and i'm a lawyer with oran reno in
concord
and our clients
this afternoon are
the new hampshire association of
domestic insurance companies
uh which is a trade association of
companies that were
primarily are primarily organized under
the laws of new hampshire although
currently it includes companies that are
chartered outside of new hampshire but
doing business here
and the second client is
american property casualty insurance
association
which is a large
national trade association
whose members write workers compensation
and other coverage in new hampshire so
between the two
we represent
not all but i think most of the workers
compensation that's written in in new
hampshire
i appreciate the discussion that's taken
place on this bill and the questions
that have been asked
many of them are questions that we have
about how to interpret uh the bill uh if
we're applying i think that
i won't belabor that because i think
it's clear
that
if you are going to do something by way
of remedy
the bill needs needs a significant
amount of
clarification to
it it is subject to a lot of
interpretation i think my clients were
mostly concerned that
where there are legitimate issues why it
takes longer to make a determination
than 60 days it would be an obligation
retroactively
to pay
the increased amount of compensation
also
it is i i think unclear under the bill
whether
uh once an order
once someone is
found to be obligated to
pay the enhanced compensation how long
does that go on
uh and so
i think that's all been been covered
here pretty well
i i won't say any more about that but i
would like to mention the
existing law uh and the provisions
for requiring uh timely payment that
exist currently in the law because i
think that what we're talking about here
is if anything it's an enforcement issue
and not not a question of
uh requiring a payment because timely
payment is already required
and that requirement is contained in
several places one is
uh in the section that
this bill amends which is
um
rsa for 281 a 42
this bill as you see adds a paragraph
five but
paragraphs one through four
state what the
obligation for payment is
under the law today
and
the penalties for not making timely
payment
as the deputy commissioner mentioned
the
commissioner has the authority to assess
a civil penalty of up to 2 500
on any carrier self-insurer that fails
without sufficient cause
to
pay or deny a claim within 20 days 21
days of notice
that 2500
in my experience
is has been applied
to b every payment is additional 2500 so
you can add up to a pretty significant
number if if there's an ongoing failure
to make to make payment
um
the
further requirement in that section is
that
upon failure of any carrier self-insurer
to comply
with an order for payment of
compensation
the commissioner shall
recover either
the civil penalty or the additional
compensation both in a civil action in
the superior court or in a civil action
in the superior court
so that
power and obligation exists currently in
the law upon the labor commissioner
furthermore
under
paragraph 4
of
section
of rsa281-842
and i think this is significant and
often overlooked
the commissioner shall submit to the
insurance commissioner
the record of an insurance carrier who
consistently fails to comply with the
provisions of this section
if the insurance commissioner should
upon investigation
find the carrier to be in substantial
non-compliance
the commissioner shall order compliance
if the commit if the insurance
commissioner shall fail to comply
insurance
the carrier shall fail to comply
the insurance commissioner shall suspend
or revoke such carriers authorization
to carry out the business
workers compensation in this state
that's a pretty strong power and a
pretty strong a penalty that would be
imposed the very
lifeblood of a company its ability to do
business in the state
um
and and i think
that
this power knowing the insurance
department
would be uh exercised if the department
were made aware of violations because no
one wants
my clients or anyone wants a company to
do business in this state that is
willfully delaying
uh payments made to
uh an injured and injured worker that
just doesn't that just doesn't fit uh
any
profile of what a company should should
be doing
i think we're mostly talking about
inadvertent
failures to make timely payment and
these are going to occur from time to
time pattern of failure then i think
that should be
uh subject and i think the law already
provides for it
for the the harshest
uh of of penalties people the companies
don't belong in new hampshire if they're
doing this and i am mindful
my memory is a little vague but i
remember a few years ago that there was
a carrier that was arguably uh
engaging in that conduct and again if
memory serves i think that the
they were called to task pretty
seriously and that the uh there was
again if i recall correctly
a hefty fine and that the the actions of
that company uh were
its conduct was uh was addressed
by the by the department of labor so i
think the tools exist right now i should
mention too that under the insurance
laws
which apply to workers compensation
there's an unfair trade practices act
that applies to claims and among those
requirements is
is the requirement that payments be made
promptly claims payment that's rsa 417
and that
uh
that um
statute is supplemented by rule 1000 of
the insurance department which goes into
detail about a timely payment of claims
and that that would apply
to workers compensation claims payments
also there is uh labor rule 500
50602 of which provides that a carrier
shell or employer shall pay all claims
as quickly as possible
and the rule goes on to
define
the obligation and the penalties that
would apply in the event of
non-compliance so i think what we have
here
is
an issue not of
the requirements of the statute but of
enforcement of uh what already exists in
the law and
um
it's hard from based on the testimony to
at least for me to get a handle on how
extensive the
the issue is
and and uh
the problem is but even if there are 10
complaints
at any given time there shouldn't be
and uh
so
we're happy to work with the department
uh and if what is called for is a
reminder to carriers of their obligation
i'm happy to participate in that
i think that the uh
the
department of labor is
able to
get that reminder out to uh carriers and
and that
can't speak for the department of
insurance but i think that they too who
regulate the licenses of insurance
companies including workers comp
insurance companies in this state
uh might and they've done this sort of
thing in the past
either by bulletin or some notice to all
carriers doing business in the state
uh
uh emphasize the importance of timely
payments of workers compensation i just
suggest that as one possible way to
approach the issue before we
talk about making statutory changes that
like anything else have
unintended consequences the
again i won't be labor but the
this will certainly increase costs if
uh
for one thing if if if if an employee is
going to receive 100 of
his or her wage
uh i mean 60 100 percent versus 60
tax-free
uh that
there's an incentive not to go back uh
to work so that's one reason that
that there is a reduction from 100 in
what
is received under disability policies
privately or under workers compensation
also
again depending on how this bill is
written
it would have a chilling effect on
uh on the denial of claims that should
be denied by an insurance company
because of the exposure if they're later
found to have an obligation to have
provided coverage
and if
this hundred percent penalty is going to
be retroactive to
uh sometime in the past
when the
the matter should have been
uh should have been accepted so i'll
leave it i'll leave it at that but i
think these are a couple of examples
where maybe
the uh
the remedy could be
looked at a little bit
more before you decide whether to enact
legislation in this area thank you mr
thank you for your testimony
representative cahill
thank you mr chair thank you mr ruthless
your testimony has been very helpful uh
there's a few things i didn't know i
know the chairman of course knew all of
this but
i didn't know about the insurance
department's having that other
uh
hand in this so
um
and it would also be quite a a
disruption for the customers of that
insurance people with their work not
long no longer offering the plan in the
state and all of a sudden they're
they had no workers comp but could you
tell me
i think these the sponsor's main issue
here was the
preliminary payment and the delay the
delay in that do you have any
information on how long it generally
takes to process a claim or
how how bad a problem this this is from
your perspective
thank you i i um
i would like to defer to the labor
department uh to to answer that i think
they'd have a much better account
on that i think so that
well i don't i think it's fair to say
that that these problems are
are not the the rule but the exception
and that most most cases are
uh clearly um
uh work-related uh accidents or injuries
and and and they're paid and as the
system's designed to do without lawyers
or controversy to to just in a no-fault
system to have uh have the payment
made and timely made but in terms of uh
statistics i think the department would
because they'll get a first report of
injury from the employee and then the uh
the report from the employer or the
carrier and uh so
uh they may have actual records that
would that would be uh helpful in
answering your question well the deputy
ogden did say roughly roughly perhaps 10
a month
but perhaps perhaps there's other
detailed reports we could get and see
just the ones that don't get a complaint
how often how long it takes yes
thank you very much and i thank you and
i i will ask mr chairman i i will ask uh
carriers um the first reaction that i
got in talking with carriers is they
they were not aware of a problem but
that doesn't necessarily
you know fully answer the question and i
i will check back based on the testimony
of the sponsor and the department and uh
see if i can learn anything more that's
helpful but thank you very much thank
you
any other question mr russos whoever
does mandeville you're
recognizing i'm sorry brian you do
mandeville and representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman the uh unfair
claims practices or trade practices acts
in this state to which you referred do
they contain any kind of trouble damages
or other remuneration for a successful
uh claimant
there is uh thank you
there is a private right of action
uh that exists under that statute um
uh it i believe
is not does not provide enhanced damages
but i think it provides for attorneys
fees and uh in fairness i should say
that that's very very seldom uh used but
to answer your question it is in the law
with respect to a violation of
of that statute uh especially on a
finding by the commissioner
that the statute has been violated i
think it's crime of facial evidence in a
civil action uh that there's been a
violation followed mr chairman
and and not only attorney's fees but
compensatory damages presumably would be
included thank you
it is my understanding you are correct
there are no trouble damages when it
comes to the insurance
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
russos for your input i'd like to
clarify something i think i heard you
already speak to
attach the bill we have the department
of labor is unsure
whether this will increase premiums for
state county local government
the sponsor actually said he didn't
think there would be any increase in
cost but i think i heard you say it will
absolutely be an increase in cost
specifically
i'm trying to quantify this first state
county and local yes no i i i
i'm not an actuary or anything but uh i
i think it would be hard to conceive of
uh
anything other than an increase in costs
if if you're paying in in whatever
number of cases 100 of a wage rather
than 60 percent of a wage for some
indeterminate period of time
uh at the state and local and county
level
that that would increase
costs i also think that
that the chilling effect that this would
have depending on how the bill is read
on
the ability of a company to deny claims
which is
their right and obligation on behalf of
the employer to deny a claim that they
don't think is compensable
but sometimes they're going to be held
to be have been mistaken and if you go
back retroactively it's it's it's a it's
a big amount potentially that they would
be exposed to and they're going to think
about that before they uh decide whether
to contest a claim or not and
so that's another policy question i
think if if
there is a serious interest
as you know ncci is the
real authority on uh
with its actuaries on the effects of
legislation on on
on the cost of insurance lost costs of
insurance and
and uh you you might consult with them
but my sort of
uh
layman's
view of it is that i think it would
certainly increase costs
thank you
thank you i see no other questions thank
you mr resource thank you mister
i have no further pink cards there
anyone from the audience who would like
to uh
further opine on house bill 1231 fn
seeing none i'm closing the hearing on
hospital 12 31
and we have uh three or four minutes
until we open our next bill
representative
um
on page
workers compensation reform to
compromise
well
yeah under the first uh i would say nine
lines
no i mean you know i've seen this a lot
when people want to they're trying to
make their point before they change the
law i've seen much more inflammatory
things
free
thank you pre-employment background
investigation
i will recognize representative trottier
to introduce this bill
good afternoon thank you mr chair and
members of this committee
i am douglas trottier i am a
representative in district 6 out of
belmont
today before you i'm
presenting house bill 1156 fn
which pertains to
the pre-employment background
investigations being released to
certain candidates
my intent is to allow
applicants
or candidates who apply for any public
service position including fire ems
police nursing or other public service
positions and are required to take a
background or submit to a background
investigation
to
be able to attain a copy of the said
background report
upon completion
the current practice of most
public employees will not allow that
speaking with some police administer
reason why they do not release that
information
it falls under rsa five fleet standards
and training does have a class on it
that is a guideline but not a standard
so each individual agencies can develop
their own standards on how they do
background investigations
okay
the information that is in the
background investigation pertains to
the candidate or applicant himself or
herself and should be entitled to that
um
some of the information that has been
released you know i would like to see
if somebody's doing a background on a
public servant and they contact their
employer
that it's in the personnel file
what i have come to seen in some
agencies
that
administrators actually keep a secret
file that
the employee has no
knowledge of and they present that
to a background investigator or
the powder hearsay
is another thing i do not feel hearsay
should be part of a background
investigation
there's many examples i mean because
people can say whatever they want so
if there's going to be hearsay use i
think it should have to be
something that they can provide hard
evidence or documentation for an example
if all of a sudden a
police officer um
you know goes for a
job in an
excuse in the background investigation
a
administrator or somebody that has
spoken to says hey just so you know this
officer has received a write-up for this
behavior
okay if that's in the
personnel file then i understand that
can be used but if that is incorrect and
there's no documentation of that that
should not be able to be used
because false information can be
portrayed
incorrectly so at this point for an
example two now one thing we've been
dealing with in the house is the
exculpatory list or the lorry list
sometimes offices have been put on that
list without even knowing so
and
they go for a a position with another
agency or
another um public service job and that
comes up and they had no way of
defending themselves i know that's
something we're working on to correct
but this information pertains to the
candidate and they should have the right
to that
i know there has been a recent case in
the merrimack county
superior court over a matter like this
and
the argument was when the person asked
for the background investigation report
the argument was that under 5 16 39 that
was an internal investigation and that's
why it could not be released
the superior court judge ruled
differently and said that a candidate is
not a employee which is required under
the internal investigations
the judge said that just because you're
given a conditional offer that statute
does not apply and
mandated that it would be turned over to
the candidate
because it was information information
pertaining to themselves
then
it was appealed to the supreme court and
the supreme court ruled
in favor
with the
superior court judge
so at this time
i'm not sure why
um anybody in an administrative position
in fire service police
uh ems
will not release that information
um
again you're not asking for somebody
else's information or anything like that
it's pertaining to yourself so you
should know what's being said
about you as a candidate so if it's
something you can correct
um
you correct it i mean it could be
the part of a
they do a credit report and you might
have a bad credit report
and you don't get the job or whatever
and you don't know that
and there's no way of correcting that
it could be somebody went through a hard
time went through a divorce something
happened it's something that could be
corrected
so at this point that's why i'm asking
that you know we look at this bill
and pass it
the other thing is in my bill is
you know
being able to pass information from one
background investigator from one agency
to another one be prohibited
because there's no standard one
department can do it one way another
department can do with another
so they should not be able to pass
information on
because
it could be false information and that
could
be defamation or harming to a person's
future career in public service
so that's basically the bill
basically so i'm asking this committee
to please consider this and you know
make it fair so
any candidate in the public service can
have a fair shot at future employment
and to correct issues
thank you for your testimony how many
questions for the presenter
representative cahill
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for bringing forward this
bill
um
i'm wondering
you know if if this is a this is a
criminal background check and if there's
nothing
criminally that you that the officer or
firefighter has done
um
why why does that turn up in their
personnel file
um
this is not a criminal it's a
pre-employment pre-employment ic thank
you for the qualification i mean more
than likely if you are going for a
public service position you do sign a
waiver to get
a criminal record check done
but i mean if you are a
candidate in
something on your criminal record you
should know about that it's more
concerning when things are being said or
provided that the candidate has no idea
about
follow up
um
is there also an issue where like maybe
your current employer doesn't know that
you're looking for another position and
you maybe you'd rather they didn't know
is this a little awkward to have someone
checking with your current employer no i
mean i
you know i mean some people
do
fear retaliation if they don't get the
job
um but
usually you know it should be the part
that you're honest with them hey i'm
looking for another job or whatever and
there are administrators out there that
do get upset
um and that's what i'm not looking at
it's when they provide
hearsay that they cannot back up
or they they say something happened to
somebody and there's no proof of that
like
my example was if all of a sudden you
know
you're the chief and somebody comes in
and does a background in one of your
offices you have a personality conflict
you have um
or he's upset that you applied for
another job and then all of a sudden you
say hey you know what this guy
he was a problem he was always showing
calling out sick showing up late doing
this
well if it was a big problem why
wouldn't you do a write-up and have it
in his personnel file and let him know
but then all of a sudden you do that
when they go for another job you give
that information which might be false
thanks very much
representative abalone
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking the question and testifying
before us
under public employer on the first page
line 18 and 19
could you
just clarify what an any quasi public
corporation is
on the first page
yes sir
i don't see it why not 19.
you don't have lines i do not have okay
second paragraph in this section
halfway down public employer shall mean
which will mean the state and public
subdivisions
i can't answer that that was something
that when the bill was written
um
that was put in there
and i'm willing to amend that
thank you mr chairman
i think legislative service is right
sided a lot um i have a few questions oh
i'm sorry
representative mandeville you're
recognized oh thank you mr chairman
would you rather go first no thank you
um thank you representative
for
testifying uh
obviously this this addresses the right
to have access to the um
report but also contains
the section starting it well our line 11
that that
what the employer can use or won't use
and you've talked about hearsay
as
i think being your prime
focus of what an employer shouldn't use
or is not able to use to me the
tricky question is what hearsay is and i
don't know if you intended by
that word to track with what a legal
meaning of hearsay was
uh including with all its exceptions
or something more
like lay term just something heard from
someone else which itself
is a difficult concept so if you could
elaborate a little on how you
would think we would understand and if
necessary reign in the concept of
hearsay for use here okay
so basically if all of a sudden a
background investigator goes in and
speaks to an individual about that
applied for a position
they go into their agency or their place
of employment and
the person they spoke with says hey you
know i heard this person has
this in their personal
personnel file
but
so
and there the investigator says can you
provide that for me no it's only
something i heard from you know a past
person that worked here or
um somebody even before that it's just
something i've never seen anything like
this
but that's what i heard
so that's what i'm saying for hearsay
meaning by hearsay so if all of a sudden
you know
that same situation hey i heard that you
know this person did have a write-up for
this and they go into their personnel
file
and it's there
then it can be used
i want something that's going to match
up with the hearsay
as hard proof for documentation
also
representative turcotte
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my questions representative um
first question i have is
rsa 275 56
applies to pretty much any employee and
every employer in the state
yet the additional paragraph you're
proposing to add 275 56 a
um
uh pertains only to public employers why
would this not pertain to
private employers
um because i was focusing on the public
more than
the private
because more than likely
public employees are going to ask for
background investigations or ask you to
to submit to one compared to
the private
follow up thank you mr chairman
thank you for that answer um
the next question i have is
under the definition of
public servant
it's going to be down close to the
bottom of your page where it talks about
uh
public servants shall mean a list of the
following and it there's a several in
that are included in there that
i'm kind of wondering why they're
including one one legislators why would
a legislator
fall under the term public servant for
the
uh for in terms of pre-employment
background checks
there's a couple other ones i guess you
could make the argument for also you
know why
why are they included
um again when they wrote it
i explained to them what i wanted and i
thought that might have already been in
there so that's why i did not remove it
if they were not i have no problem um
amending that and having it removed
representative one more follow-up thank
you mr chairman uh final follow-up um
since this is
targeted to uh public employers i'm
assuming most
you know firemen
police in general or or whatever
is is there a
reason this
could not be something that you could
obtain in a collective bargaining
agreement
look good good question a lot of small
agencies
do not and not just that not all
candidates or applicants are in a union
true i understand that
my my point is you could include i'm
as an example i
as part of my union i have
access to my personal files and that's
included in our collective bargaining
agreement
why could
is there a reason why you could not
include in
say
you police or firemen i don't even know
which what i'm assuming you want one of
the two why could
that not be including in collective
bargain bargaining agreement even to
include a
pre-employment background check
i'm sorry if i didn't ask that as
clearly as possible
just trying to think of the appropriate
way to explain it
[Music]
because i
because most people are most
administrators are gonna fight this as
you're gonna probably hear in testimony
coming up
um
so i don't think it's the appropriate
place to put it in a bargaining unit
thank you mr chairman thank you thank
you
senator sullivan followed by adagent
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
following up on what rep uh turcotte was
uh talking about a minute ago
line 21 refers to
be public servant
um
would it not be more appropriate to have
public employee there rather than
servant
because we're talking about a
pre-employment background check
and
public servants a lot of the public
servants that are listed there are not
employees yeah may i interrupt for a
second before you answer the question
just so i'm not confused here
is the only part we're talking about of
adding is and pre-employment background
checks as emboldened and the rest is
current law
okay i have that wrong
okay thank you i apologize i just want
to make sure we're on the same page here
representative sullivan asked a question
if you still recall the question uh you
can pretty repeat that please sure no
sorry
um
i was looking down at section uh roman
two
uh part b
refers to public servant and i was
questioning whether or not public
servant ought to be public employee
because you've got a public employer
above that
and employers
have employees
not servants
yes that that could be amended okay
thank you
very much
thank you mr chairman um
there there seems to be a little
confusion around
uh
public servants and uh the list of
specific titles um can you see any
reason why an amendment to just
make it anybody that has to undergo a
background check
uh couldn't receive a copy of that
are you looking for private and public
or
public i would be
with the liberty of the chair to explain
context i would be interested in
submitting an amendment to broaden it
uh to private and public but i'm asking
you because you are more familiar with
the rsa than i am having explored it um
whether
you could see any reason why that would
be a problem
right off hand now
follow a question uh just a quick
follow-up um you also uh expressed a
moment ago that you might have some
familiarity with union negotiations um
would you agree
that
um by removing a component from
negotiation allows both the union the
management to focus on other parts of
the contract
that they might be more interested in
reaching negotiations on versus burning
fuel on
uh claiming a background check
yeah i could i could see them spending
more time
on other pads if we didn't have to deal
with this in the union contract thank
you
any further questions any further
questions
i i have a couple i just want to i've
never seen this in 16 years on this
committee so bear with me here
there are certain
jobs
in the state of new hampshire you were
specifically looking at police fire emts
is what you've mentioned a few times
if you would like to
possibly get employed by the state of
new hampshire
or or town or whatever or if you would
like to
possibly
get a promotion or a higher ranking job
within those if you're already in them
you need to have a pre-employment
background check
is that correct
is that what you're trying to say so
basically if you are going for a if
you're a new candidate to an agency
police fire
some ems
you they re they ask you to submit to a
background investigation yes
once you're in the agency
and there is a promotion i don't believe
they're going to ask to do another
background on you because you're already
working for them okay
so if all of a sudden you're working for
one agency now
and
you decide you know what i want to go to
a larger agency smaller agency and you
apply
then you go through their process and
then
they
they're going to consider you for the
position
then they'll give you a conditional
offer
and then do a background investigation
background investigation can include
a credit check
possibly a criminal background check yes
from the either the state or the feds
um
anything else they can go see your talk
to your fellow employees your current
you know what what the extent so most
you know i'm more experienced on the law
enforcement side
um so once you get that you know it's
assigned to a background investigator
you know um you fill out this
questionnaire you give it to them
they'll do a credit report normally
they'll do a
colonel record a motor vehicle record
past employment they'll talk with
employees they're supposed to talk to
your
significant other
family members
very similar as a friend of mine went to
work for the nsa
fbi came to see me something somewhere
like that getting a background check
asking questions all right so
you have all this stuff done
you either do receive the job
or you pass the cred to check and and
they
follow through with the conditional
offer
or you fail and you don't
you would like
to be able to review what is in that
the information that was
uh obtained through that background
check yes
what reason
would
the
entity
that
requested that background check to be
done
not want to provide it to you
i
i can't speak for
them
are you aware if there's any
potential
legal
action that could be taken against the
people who
perform the report and that's the
concern
that could be because if all of a sudden
somebody gives false information
defamation
or something like that i would take it
there would be
civil action
would you think an individual who was
denied would want to be able to see
that report
to see if there's something in there
that's
possibly wrong because someone used an
incorrect
name initial or social security number
to obtain that information no
i have well my point is wouldn't you
want to correct it if something's wrong
yes
thank you
okay
i have no further questions anyone else
mark representative warden thank you
do you know of any circumstances where
employees or employee candidates have
used the right to know request 91a to
try to get that information that would
be required here whether that's been
difficult to get
um
i've heard of
you know
people have tried to get under 91a and
was denied
the case that i'm thinking about i don't
think it was a 98 a 91 a request
it was actually compelled by a court
any further questions of the
representative
xenon thank you very much for your
testimony thank you very much like to
call joseph
obeck or becky
new hampshire a-a-c-o-p
did i say that correctly sir close
enough oh becky
i'm sorry one more time hold becky oh
becky thank you apologies nope no
problem
it's not it's not a name like smith or
jones so i have some written testimony i
would
feel free to mention sir yes please
you're well yes you're welcome to do so
all right good afternoon mr chair
members of the committee my name is
joseph hobecky and i'm the chief of
police in hollis new hampshire
i also serve as the current president of
the new hampshire association of chiefs
of police
i testify before you this afternoon
in opposition to house bill 1156 as
introduced by representative trottier
let me first say that although i respect
genuinely respect representative
representative trottier's position on
this bill
i must disagree with his assertion
on the issues he identified in respond
in saying that this bill is not
necessary
and will harm what are
and should remain rigorous and stringent
hiring process processes
i often say a phrase when we talk about
hiring
in our agency and with other law
enforcement practitioners show me a bad
police officer and i'll show you a bad
background investigation and i've found
that to be true
most often
within the bill most glaringly is the
fact that the bill uses the term the
employer which would lead one to assume
that a candidate for a position within a
public service entity
is an employee
this is clearly not the case and as such
a candidate is and should not be
entitled to receive a copy of the
investigatory background report
my second point of argument comes with
the following language
and if you could refer to the bill
respectfully i ask you to do so
if you look at lines 12 through
and i'll read it directly
the employer shall not use any prior
arrest charge detention information
in determining a candidate's suitability
if such arrests or charge was dropped or
if the candidate was found not guilty at
trial or annulled by a court
this is very problematic for several
reasons most notable of which is the
fact that it conflicts with the
requirements set forth within police
standards and training policy
301.05 which i've attached to my
testimony
if you look at subsections subsection g
numbers 2 3 4 5 and 15 which i've
highlighted
these certainly apply to the language
contained within the bill that's before
you
in our direct conflict with these
requirements
i would also note that just because a
person has had a charge annulled
that that a charge was dropped or that
an applicant was not found not guilty of
a charge does not mean that this would
eliminate questions regarding the
character and reputation of that person
that is specifically dealt with in
subsection 15.
moreover this should not hinder an
agency's determination and right to
refuse suitable
employment
to a person
they feel would not be a suitable
candidate for positions within public
service like law enforcement where
individuals are entrusted with immense
powers and responsibilities
in the 20 plus years i've served as a
police officer i've conducted a lot of
background investigations
for both sworn and non-sworn applicants
as any law enforcement executive will
tell you
recruitment and selection of officers is
one of the most important if not the
most important function of a law
enforcement agency
this also extends to other public
service agencies as well such as police
fire etc etc
numerous times i have recommended the
disqualification of applicants
which stem from information developed
from witnesses who are not listed in an
applicant's personal history
questionnaire
as you are aware there's been
considerable scrutiny in conversation
about police hiring practices
and how vetting processes or lack
thereof
have allowed individuals with
suitability issues to slip through the
proverbial cracks
as such this is not the time
nor should it ever be the time
to diminish the ability of law
enforcement agencies to conduct thorough
and complete background investigations
and to make a decision to disqualify an
applicant given information gleaned from
their investigation
there is already a process which
representative trottier spoke to and
some of you spoke to as well
for a person who feels aggrieved given
the outcome of a background
investigation or hiring decision
and that process is through civil
litigation
if a person does not agree with the fire
a finding they can simply simply follow
civil process
and ask that a court decide whether a
finding regarding the suitability for
employment or release of such
information is legitimate or was
legitimate
finally i would be remiss if i did not
mention the privacy issues that might
arise when
if this bill were to pass what i'm
referring to
is those who cooperate with the
background investigation and provide
information
detrimental to an applicant's
suitability for employment
and this happens
developed references those are the
references we look at those are the
references outside
the references in which an applicant
lists on their application and
oftentimes they possess the best
information about a candidate and their
suitability for employment
and those people that we speak to they
operate under the assumption that the
information they are providing will be
held in confidence and not
used as a tool of retaliation
and this is critical
my last few points i just want to
mention a few things first of all the
exculpatory evidence schedule
was a topic that was raised
there
was a bill that was passed 105
r 105 13 d
which clarifies the process
that the attorney general in the state
of new hampshire will follow in order to
have a vetting process for officers who
have exculpatory
information in their background and to
allow that information become public so
there is already a process in place for
that
and that's law
there's there was a bill passed last
legislative session i believe it was
signed by the governor in november rsa
226 1 colon 1
which deals with release of background
information to law enforcement agencies
and so other agencies can call another
law enforcement agency
and obtain information relative to
background investigation
to me
this seems like an issue with individual
agency process
representative trottier spoke
a lot about individual agency process
and procedure
and to me this bill is not necessary
because the issue comes within those
specific agencies that maybe don't
follow a set process and procedure
lastly
if you've ever conducted any type of
hiring process you will know that
non-public employees
trying to get information from a
non-public employer
is extremely difficult and oftentimes
you can only get confirmation of dates
of employment and maybe if you're lucky
salary information
so with that
i ask you to to please respectfully
please find the spill in expedient to
legislate
and i will certainly answer any
questions that you may have
thank you representative seaworth
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your testimony
early on in your testimony you
made a statement about a candidate who
is rejected is not an employee and
therefore
shouldn't be entitled to
resp
are you aware
of the supreme court decision that the
sponsor referenced and
the scope of that and how that
intersects with your statement i'm not
aware of that
um
and and i wouldn't feel comfortable
commenting on it but i can certainly
research that and provide further
clarification to the committee if needed
fair enough thank you thank you
chief i have a few questions for you yes
sir
you got me in a rock and a hard place
here chief
because i have a lot of
admiration and respect for the
law enforcement
i'm tossed here as to what you're asking
us to do
first off i don't think anyone has a
problem with
would you would you imagine or what you
was trying to say
would you believe
i have no problem with removing
the items you talked about through lines
12 through 16
regarding the suitability and
previous
detentions arrest charges et cetera even
if they're annulled
but i don't understand
the concern
that a and i'm not calling an employer
because you know that as well a
prospective employer i guess would be an
appropriate word
how would you like it if you didn't get
a position for something and you
couldn't find out
why if there was anything in that
investigation without filing a civil
lawsuit
from my experience
mr chair
when a person is denied employment
and i'll speak as a chief if i deny
employment to a candidate based on a
suitability issue that candidate will be
provided with a reason why they're
denied employment
they don't just simply receive a phone
call or a letter in the mail it says you
know thanks for applying we're not
moving forward there's whether it's a
two or three sentence explanation as to
why
uh they were disqualified from
consideration is provided because we
don't want those questions for can that
you know we don't want a candidate to
have those questions but in my
experience and i've done a lot of these
over the years candidate knows exactly
why they're disqualified
they know exactly why they're
disqualified there are rigorous
processes
particularly with police and law
enforcement background checks multiple
stages within a hiring process that we
follow
and so it comes as no surprise it should
come as no surprise to any candidate why
they're denied employment
it's just it's not my experience and
it's
i i just feel this bill is not needed
it's not necessary
another question um
you mentioned the process
of
the civil
so if someone is denied they want to
know why
under current law
you would not provide them
a file of your background check
you mentioned they have to file a civil
proceeding
did i hear it correctly in saying that
if they choose to fall
should they choose to do that
i guess i'm trying to find out is it a
futile effort to do that because
in your case if this was you you would
it wouldn't be um
discoverable or would it be
that file
or that background check so it's one
thing to file a civil suit it's another
one for the person receiving the civil
suit to ask for a summary judgment
because based on another law you're not
going to get it anyway
can i give you a scenario please okay
so within hollis we operate a
communication center and it's a regional
dispatch center
and although they're not part of the
police department
um they're a town agency and they're
governed by an advisory board in which i
sit on
last year we had an applicant
applied for a position with as a
dispatcher
and in the process of his initial
pre-employment questionnaire
he provided information
that the detective then verified
was inaccurate and it involved the case
with a domestic situation with the
former intimate partner
and
this young lady was very concerned about
the confidentiality of the information
she was providing
and he was denied employment for that
because it was a serious issue and it
impacted his credibility as a public
servant
um
a few and he was provided notification
why he was
disqualified from employment
a few weeks after i received a letter
from an attorney
um requesting a copy of all the files
collected relative to his background
including the background report
and when i received the letter i
certainly consulted with town council
and they told me that it was appropriate
to deny
the background packet
to this applicant for the very reasons i
just stated
and so i
i look at it not just in terms of
confidentiality mr chair but also
protecting
the agency in the town from civil
liability if i were to release
information that could then be held
against the person
that provides information to us in the
course of a background investigation
there could be serious consequences and
to be frank with you i don't want to be
associated with that and i don't want to
be responsible for that so if it comes
down to it if if a person files a
lawsuit and
a court tells me requires me to do it i
will follow the court's order but there
is already a process for that this bill
is not necessary in my humble opinion
and i say that with all due respect mr
chair
thank you for your candidate
representative sullivan
thank you for taking my question thank
you mr chairman
a few minutes ago you
you said that if you deny employment to
a candidate you
explained to them why
and then you followed that up by saying
that
this one candidate that you denied
employment to
was denied because of
um
an issue with a former intimate partner
who
wanted to have it
kept confidential how do those two
things
mesh
well obviously we'd you know we wouldn't
provide specific information about
the person providing the information
etcetera etcetera we provide them with a
a general explanation
you know and for example i can recall
the verbiage that i used for that one it
was
due to truthfulness
given your
you know
former
activities or engagement in the
information you you provided to the
background investigator on this date you
were denied employment and i can tell
you he knew exactly why he was denied
employment
there is no question
um that
that he didn't know
uh that why he was denied employment
actually a different question entirely
you um
mentioned earlier that
non-public employers
sometimes give nothing um other than
dates of employment etc i believe that
might be true of some public employers
as well
um
why why is that
i think they're genuinely i i don't know
i can give you a correct answer but my
assumption is is that they're concerned
about the confidentiality of of an
employee's uh file
you know oftentimes these these files
and records contain protected
information medical records etc etc
and so they
i think private companies have
you know have become very protective of
what's included in those files which
you know can be detrimental in some
circumstances i would agree with that
thank you
i'm not sure which both of you
representative i will only follow or
take a lot of time governor of turcotte
followed by abulani whatever thank you
mr chairman thank you for taking my call
my call my question i know what you
meant
um you were mentioning that you've been
doing this for quite a few years and i
so i'm assuming you've done uh many of
these background checks
you also mentioned that um
the individual being denied the job
generally knows and i would tend to
agree what i would think that would be
the case
how many of your denials have actually
res give me a ballpark on how many times
you've denied an applicant employment
and then how many times your denials
have resulted in a civil suit
uh no civil suits
one request for background report which
is the one i just spoke to the chair
about
and in total
i've done at least
i'm not trying to inflate this but this
is just an estimate
background investigation personally
between 75 and 100
in my time and
obviously as a chief i in the final
decider of employment for folks so
i hope i answered your question that was
perfectly answered thank you thank you
representatives
thank you mr chairman thank you chief
for taking the question
um
the pre-employment background check if
if it is successful would become part of
the permanent file of the personal file
of the employee that is correct yes
having said that there are parts that
would potentially be protected medical
records uh psychological examination etc
etc
yes please so they would not have access
to their psychology psychologically they
would outside employees may not
necessarily have that
typically when we do backgrounds we have
an applicant fine
file a a waiver form
which permits us in contacting say if if
i'm hiring a certified police officer
and i'm doing a background
or one of my personnel is doing a
background
and they reach out to the other agency
agencies will ask for that waiver uh for
release of information because they want
to protect themselves from
not releasing information they shouldn't
i hope i answered your question
yes thank you so so all that
investment investor
investigatory paperwork would be part of
the permanent file
yes that's correct yes anything we
gather and collect throughout the course
of an investigation background
investigation would be part of their
personnel file
and one last one sure
here in new hampshire most most if not
all employees
that are currently working or fired or
moved on to other jobs have access to
their personnel files yes
would there be anything that
would be precluded
out of the pre-employment background
check that an applicant would not be
available to get
i guess i i don't really understand your
question you talked about employers as
opposed to applicants
correct if there's an applicant that has
you have an employee who's
has total access to your employment file
that's correct i have an applicant that
is looking for a pre-employment
background check report
of some sort or why they were denied
if it became part of their permanent
file
why would it not be
why would we not be giving it to them
to the applicant correct
well i mean my take is an employee is
entitled to those records they're an
employee an applicant's not an employee
thank you thank you mr chairman
thank you
representative representative mandeville
thank you thank you chief uh for your
testimony um i understand the back and
forth about the access to information my
concern as i mentioned to representative
charity is a little different
uh it's based on my read whether it's
correct or not of the sentence that
starts at line 11
the source of any information used
by the employer to determine a candidate
candidate's suitability for employment
shall be in writing and shall not be
based on hearsay
that that seems to govern it seems to me
to govern to some extent what the
employer
can rely on or not
and of course
as we know you know
virtually every document is itself a
piece of hearsay um and
um
and and just to give an example let's
say a
fire chief was looking at a candidate
and called the next town overs fire
chief who had employed this person
before and the
other town chief said
well we thought he was starting fires
but we couldn't prove it so we just let
him go well that's rank hearsay as i
read this that would not be able to be
considered by
the hiring department
and if it were written down in a report
that would be double hearsay so it would
be doubly impermissible that's my
concern i uh do you h a share that
concern and b
if this were acceptable to you in terms
of access to documents or restriction of
access to documents is there a way you
could see
that would fit to make
the uh review process as to suitability
better
i am i am concerned about the the
hearsay piece representative i think
it's extremely confusing and i would i i
feel as though it would restrict an
agency's ability to conduct a fair and
thorough investigation
i can tell you a lot of witnesses
develop references
listed references
when they speak to you on the phone
that's what they're engaging in they're
providing hearsay and you know certainly
investigators a good investigator is
going to attempt to corroborate that
some things can't be corroborated
however i don't think it should be
limited that we can't use that as a
determination or disqualifier of
employment i think any good agency is
going to do their homework to determine
the suitability of a candidate and
that's just one piece of the puzzle
i have one last question
chief you know we got an insurance agent
you got a campground owner we got pilot
you know
we don't do background checks i
understand
so we're not used to how this goes
so are you familiar with chief ranch
dewey
i i am he's a good friend yes well we
went to high school together so i have
some good stories
but if i were asked
x amount of years ago when he entered
the
police
force
um
if i was asked questions and had to ask
truthfully whatever i might say some
things about our high school antics
please try to express to me how
well in your tenure of having to do
these as you mentioned you had done a
number of these
that you're not going to take one piece
of information one person and you're
gonna even if it's bad you know
something really bad
um that
what you do to make sure that you
check all of that out to make sure
whether that was just we were friends of
high school but say i didn't like him at
the time
just uh an angry took my girlfriend away
an angry guy versus you know you know
what kind of background do you do when
you do these things it really makes sure
convince us
that
we don't have to be worried about what
you hear or say sure
so
i work for an accredited law enforcement
agency and we have very rigorous
standards on on hiring
and um my whole career i've worked for
accredited agencies so we have
um
you know standards we have to meet in
terms of recruitment and hiring without
those
having said that
the police academy has rigorous
standards defined in their policies
that agencies must follow
when they conduct background
investigations
i found in my experience that
suitability for employment is a totality
of information it's not just based on
maybe what one or two people say
most candidates frankly
are disqualified even before they get to
a background investigation and if they
make it oftentimes we see a high number
of candidates who are filtered out
during the polygraph examination
um so there are very rigorous steps and
this is not oh you know john smith said
that uh joe schmoe
is a bad employee if that information is
provided
a good investigator
is going to corroborate that information
to the best of their availability
whether it's verifying that information
in some type of personnel record that
they may have with the previous employer
or developing
additional references that they can
speak to
and i'll use the example if i call john
smith and john smith says joe schmoe is
a bad employee you don't want him
working for him the next question is
explain to me why
provide me with additional people i can
speak to that can corroborate that
information and then i'm going to do the
same thing with those people i speak to
it's not just a one-and-done type
scenario
they're these investigations are
extensive they're time-consuming in
reality one background investigation
could equal 80 between 80 to 120 hours
if not more
so these aren't just done whimsically or
with the lack of process and
standardization maybe there are agencies
that do it that way but from my
experience
as a police officer agencies are very
careful with hiring
which is because of the quote i told you
you show me a bad cop i'll show you a
bad background investigation report we
understand
the incredible importance
that is associated with recruitment and
hiring and it all starts with
recruitment selection of police officers
and i hope i answered your question
thank you any further questions for our
chief
representative babyloni
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking that another question sure
um so the police standards and training
sets a minimum requirement for a
background investigation whatever
whatever minimum requirements just to
make their academy
so that is the minimum saying that each
department would have to have and then
the department would have to have
additional or equal to that minimum
standard that's correct yes thank you
guys
all right thank you very much
appreciate it
thank you mr question thank you
i i cannot read the last card i hear i
cannot read
cursive uh it looks like lori
oh that was the rep that was the
lobbyist okay we're going to wait a few
minutes here um want
yes please
thank you
lieutenant brennan davey you have to
state police welcome to the
labor committee
thank you sir my name is brendan davey i
am a lieutenant who is the commander of
the new hampshire state police
recruitment and training unit
having been present for and listen to
the testimony up to this point being
aware of the bill as introduced
i to stand in opposition
of this bill
and state that
my primary concern and i've heard the
question
posed in a couple of different ways why
why why is it that we would oppose this
bill
my primary concern is is that of the
chilling effect that i believe this bill
will have
on the ability of law enforcement
agencies to conduct thorough
investigations into what we're required
to verify
by virtue of the rules of police
standards and training councils
background investigation guidelines
which include
verifying good character
character and convictions are are two
very different things
i think we all
can think of people who managed not to
have very many convictions
and and had terrible character
our job especially given
the reform that we've seen within the
last year and a half or so within law
enforcement to include the lee act
commission
and governor's executive order 202019
which specifically
compels us when conducting background
investigations to ensure that candidates
have not demonstrated
a tendency toward unlawful bias toward
any protected parties
the virtue the reason
the means by which we will develop
and confirm any such concerns
will mostly be through what has been
accurately described as hearsay it will
be testimonial
if
all who speak to law enforcement
officers in the conduct of background
investigations
for prospective law enforcement officers
have a reason to believe
that whatever it is they express will be
disclosed right back to the very subject
of the investigation
i find it
very difficult to believe
that what is already a difficult job
will not be made
all but impossible
um i echo the chief's concerns with
regard to um
civil liability i am familiar
with the superior court case and can
state that the superior court
did acknowledge that it was their
opinion that rsa 91a i believe it's sub
paragraph 5
does
hold background investigations as a
manner as a matter exempted from
disclosure under 91a i do also agree
with chief obecky's testimony
that
the appropriate means by which to
resolve potential issues
and aggrieved
prospective employees who didn't make it
is civil litigation
with regard to
other background investigations
performed by other agencies i can tell
you that in the four and a half years
that i've been in my position
with the hundreds of background
investigations over which i've held
primary responsibility
those other background investigations
can actually be some of the most useful
pieces of information that we get in
that we will find
patent
lies
committed by
prospective applicants
we also hold that in balance
with the question of whether or not the
applicant at the time of their filling
out their pre-employment questionnaire
with a previous
law enforcement agency had merely
forgotten
just failed to recall
or had yet to commit an act that they
have either since disclosed to us or
that we've uncovered on our own
so it's really incumbent on us in
balancing that authority that we have to
intrude into
what should be
really private places in people's lives
with our responsibility to ensure that
we're not putting
sociopaths
out on the street
with hundreds of horsepower
and weaponry
to be sure that we take every possible
source of information and balance it all
out the best that we can
lastly i would i would just uh point you
to
within the attachment that chief obecky
gave you
which are the pol rules the
administrative rules of the police
standards and training council
on page 3 of 6 section c the hiring
authority shall include in its
investigation the check of the following
sources in order to determine the
applicant's character
reliability and honesty
pursuant to below
and along with listing another a number
of sources to develop that information
past and present neighbors spouses
landlords
acquaintances and other and character
references and number eight
i will tell you that in our own
background investigations i
let our candidates know
uh to a degree that i'm sometimes not
truly comfortable with with regard to
bringing up the specter of civil
liability why it is that they did not
pass muster
a great many of those conversations
amount to what i would characterize as
time and distance
you've made some error you just got out
of college and surprised you acted like
a college kid i need to be sure you're
going to stop that
before i can
let you wear this uniform and go out and
do what we do so come back to me in and
i'll give them a certain period of time
and then there are other people who
know
as the chief testified they know exactly
what the issue is and so do i and
without even naming it
we'll we'll agree to part ways sometimes
permanently
and then there are some that are just on
the basis of what i will tell them the
totality of the circumstances in a
number of areas
of our inquiry we have significant
concerns with entrusting you with the
authority you've asked for us to to give
you
and we'll leave it at that
so
i'll state also that in my tenure i have
had
one verbal request for a background
investigation
a copy to be given to the person about
whom that investigation was conducted
and one
case that has arisen to
a form of civil litigation
i think this
proposed legislation therefore
uh
along with being problematic in many
ways
with all due respect is um
frankly not necessary
thank you testimony any questions for
the lieutenant
president seaworth followed by avalani
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
testifying
this may be a little too much of a
question given your experience is one
civil case
i'm wondering
that
should an applicant go that route
and the court
decides
to award in their favor would you think
it's likely that it might be some
partial
information that the court would look at
all the all the documents and say well
these should be turned over to the
applicant these we see reasons not to
yes sir i would expect something akin to
an in-camera review
and in the superior court case of which
i'm aware
that qualified not to be released
elsewhere
uh for
for us to look at in a controlled
environment qualification was given yes
sir
thank you mr chairman thank you lt for
taking the question yes sir um
could part of the pre-employment
background check that's being requested
be redacted
so it doesn't rise to
litigation or court review or anything
like that could there be parts of it
that could be
you know their application could be
given back to them this could be given
back to them something something to
satisfy the need to look at that
background check report so
this doesn't need to escalate further of
the chain
yes sir redaction could certainly be
a workable solution my primary concern
with it is that one will take no issue
with the letters that they see they'll
take they'll take issue exactly with
what we redact
and we'll basically be pointing
ourselves to the issue
um
and thank you for the follow-up um so
witness i don't say witness testimony
but things like that personal
confidentiality that were was given to
the officer during the investigation
i mean that could always be
obviously that would be a subject to
review but that could also be redacted
from the file
and kept
on your file because you guys must keep
filing all your applicants for a certain
amount of time
yes sir
um in
in any decent investigation
the investigator will always attempt to
generate independent corroboration
at the same time
there are times where we deal with the
lone voice crying in the wilderness and
uh the manifest weight
of what we hope will be a chorus saying
hire this amazing human being or please
don't do this to society
will resonate um yes
if redaction were a course
then
then we could redact uh
whatever was appropriate to do so yes
sir
thank you for the answer thank you mr
chairman representative cahill
thank you mr chairman and thank you
lieutenant
uh in the event that a person is not
hired and does go to the court
and the court rules in their favor
uh what would the remedy be you're still
not going to hire him would there be a a
penalty a fine or a
judgment awarded the dollar amount
yes sir
my belief is and i lack experience in
this entirely but my belief is
generally most
including those who have been our
employees who sue us civilly are not
looking to come back to the place that
has uh
proven itself so unwelcoming and rather
they seek monetary damages
thanks very much yes sir
and i have one question um regarding
your civil situation
civil means money
you know people come and get some money
but in this case
similar to when i
if you were in the room i tried to
testify against trust and criminal
justice this week
you want to find out the information you
want to get to see what was done
in your civil case
is it discoverable to get a copy of that
report
because one thing is to have a civil
suit but as i tried to explain before if
there are other laws in place that says
well that's fine you can sue us but
we're still bound under
the law not to give you a copy of this
i'm trying to find out if it's
discoverable so
filing a civil suit isn't just a
meaningless act
can they get the file if they file a
suit through
discovery
you understand i'm not concerned if not
then why bother filing a civil suit if
you can't yes sir
i do understand the question uh
if you don't know that's what i mean i i
don't i don't i cannot with authority
answer you yes or no that said i'm given
to believe based on what i've read thus
far that it does not amount to a fool's
errand
um
that while there may be multiple angles
of attack and defense um
that
from what i've seen from from the
documentation sir
i believe it is a surmountable task to
get
through civil litigation to get one's
background uh should it be probative in
the view of the court presiding
and as you said
if there's something in there that
let's say your
state police does not want to see then
that's when you go to a judge for the in
camera
and they can look at it and make that
decision
i'm confident our our legal would do
exactly attempt to do that sir yes all
right i have no further questions
representative turcotte thank you mr
chairman thank you for your testimony
we're talking a lot about uh civil cases
and all this and i just want to read or
reconfer
you've only been involved with one out
of the hundreds of
background checks you've done is that
correct that's correct sir thank you
thankfully thank you lieutenant and
thank you for what you do for our state
any further questions i see none have a
good have a good day thank you all very
much lori i'm sorry your your penmanship
is wonderful but neither the gentleman
to my right or left can read your last
name
oh
i thought that was you uh
ma'am
she is not here
it's getting late and my representatives
are fading
we're just going to give her
a position
no one ever thinks
there you go ma'am lori
i cannot um i cannot
pronounce your last name because i can't
quite read it if you wouldn't mind
introducing yourself sure you're
recognized to speak on house bill
my name is laurie ortolano
i'm from nashua
and
i serve as the vice president of right
to know new hampshire but i'm not here
um representing them on this bill
because we really
didn't know about it and hadn't taken a
look at it but it sort of tied in with a
bill that i spoke to today downstairs
regarding
access to
allowing
agencies to cross-reference
personnel files and records
for people seeking employment and we did
not support that
out of
concern that there might be information
in those records that
could be damaging and the
um or the records would not be correct
and the individual seeking employment
would never know and they could be
transmitted to agencies or departments
that
could be within the state could be
federally or could be internationally
and once they're disseminated and
they're out it would be very difficult
to get control of them and correct any
information that might be incorrect
this legislation i'm in support of
personally
as a private citizen i think
expanding it to be
relative to citizens
private citizens is a pretty good idea
the question about quasi
public
businesses i think applies to
businesses that receive funding or do a
majority of their work
for public for the public for example we
have a downtown business that's a
non-profit that receives half its
funding from city money to do
enhancements for the downtown
they would fall in as a quasi
public business and i think some utility
companies do too if they're mandated by
public entities
so
there is a public feel with that quasi
public language in there and i think
there's an opportunity to look at it in
a public sense
i'm a little bit concerned
i understood the police department's
issues and what they raised but this
bill had
broader language to other departments
beyond just the police department and i
think that um
if you are applying for a job and
they're doing a background check and
have a file
you're entitled to see what's in that
file because misinformation can be put
there and you know i think some people
may well know what's in the file but you
still have
information that could be
the use the word hearsay was stated and
we kind of said well hearsay can be
anything that said but hearsay is
something that can't be
um confirmed or
proven or
verified so not all information that
somebody would give would be hearsay
and sticking to information that is
verifiable
i think is important
you know
i understand the issue with annulling
and the character issues for what has
happened if somebody was falsely
arrested or
falsely accused of something and it
turned out not to be the case but
there's a lot of other situations that
wouldn't include that
that may affect hiring where having a
copy and getting that background check
would be useful and i don't think right
to know law would work well i think
you'd find that the departments do deny
it that the legal counsel for cities
would say don't give it out and when i
look at a whole um you know
pre-employment file i would actually
question why the whole thing is denied i
would think parts of it could be given
out
and there's even an opportunity to
redact if you think that someone's name
who provided information was to be
protected you know i'd rather see some
effort made to give some information out
than a blanket denial for a hundred
percent of it because i usually think
that's too extreme
um i did a huge right to no lawsuit in
nashua in december and
trying to get records that i thought
were public out of a assessing office
was grueling it's taken me two and a
half years and it cost me 150 grand this
is a big suit
and i wouldn't you know encourage people
to go through what i went through
and part of it was a police
investigation in the assessing office
they interviewed all the staff
and i wanted copies of those interviews
and what was
said they were actually
audio video recorded
and the city went along for 10 months
saying we're going to give them to you
we're redacting them
we'll have them month after month
they're coming they're coming and after
10 months they wrote a letter and said
they're fully denied
and i had to go into court for that
and um i look at records like that and
and their reason was hey when the people
were interviewed for a criminal
investigation they didn't know it could
become public
that's a that's a reason
are you kidding me
so
you know to have to fight over stuff
like that and use the court or in a
civil uh manner is is very time
consuming very costly you're going to be
well beyond your employment window of
finding a job and i do think there's
some some merit you know that an
individual whether they're a public
employee or a private employee is going
to want to know if there's information
in that file that can be wrong credit
checks can be wrong we know that it
happens to us
and
they need to be corrected because we're
able to get a hold of them and i think
pre
employment background checks
just the individual who is
who is applying for the job should be
able to know what's in there
thank you
thank you for your testimony are there
any
questions for the presenter
i'm sorry for being late too i was
running downstairs
thank you for your testimony
that's grace
new hampshire m.a
hi i'm h grace the new hampshire
municipal association
i believe your
card might be wrong is this hp 1156
yes thank you
um so the new hampshire municipal
association imposes 1156.
i we're particularly concerned about
lines 11 through
on the bill
it says the source of any information
used by the employer to determine a
candidate suitability for employment
shall be in writing and not based on
hearsay
hearsay is a rule of evidence
in criminal cases
it doesn't have a definition in our
statute so presumably we'd be using the
new hampshire rules
in and the definition of hearsay
uh essentially that would mean that um
any sort of statement
is not is out of court and
not is being offered for its truth and
that doesn't really make sense in the
context of
this uh
what this
appears to be trying to do
in addition
uh the lines that i've cited 11 through
indicate that basically it's this
pre-employment background check
which is
really the only basis for
denying this person um
this candidate the ability to to move on
to the next stage or to be hired
that's probably not the case there's
you know anyone who's ever hired someone
knows that there are a
series of factors that you rely on it's
not necessarily going to be solely on
one
issue
i did submit written testimony um i
hopefully you have received that
i submitted that electronically i'm
happy to take any questions that the
committee has
thank you good
testimony i see any
questions
seeing none thank you very much thank
you for hearing me have no further pink
cards does anyone else in the uh
gallery like to
justify
seeing no one i'm closing the hearing on
hospital 1156.
thank you very much for your attendance
today i would like to
hang out with a few of the republican
members of the committee except for john
mackey who's got to run
physically
thank you everybody